[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
yo what is up everybody wow we made it
goodness gracious we spent the last
month working so hard on our art for the
moving meditations 3d challenge and the
time has finally come
to check out
the top 100 artists to reveal the top
100 artists
and to announce the five lucky winners
of the challenge
um a little bit about this challenge so
we announced it at the beginning of
august and i challenge you all to take a
singular
uh project file that you saw at the
beginning of the stream in that
countdown
and make it your own change out the
character make the environment choose
from 27 unique animations
recorded by tai chi master liu jin chang
it was an incredible challenge it was
actually
the biggest turnout we've ever had 3 600
3d artists young and old new and
veterans y'all stepped up
you came
to the table you brought your best you
came to the table you stepped up to the
table one of those you know what you
know what i'm saying you guys brought
your best
i'm talking literal decades worth
of collective effort
for this challenge and we're looking at
i believe the top point
two seven percent
today on stream the best of the best the
top 100
so i am very very excited to do this
with y'all we got some incredible prizes
to give away um
we have let's see let's go over the
prizes and then we'll announce our guest
all right prize wise if you made the top
100 all right this is the first time
we've ever done this
y'all are just getting a kit bash 3d kit
of your choice that's for you so if you
see your render on stream today you
better believe it you're getting a kid
bash 3d kit of your choice
we got uh fifth and fourth place coming
in
um with two extra kit bash kits so
you're gonna get a total of three kit
bash kits to become fourth and fifth
place you also get a da vinci resolve
studio perpetual license that doesn't
mean you have to do some monthly thing
nah it's just it's yours okay
um what else we got third place you get
all that good stuff
plus a wacom intuos pro
tablet the size of your choice i use a
medium
that's what this glove is i do not have
you know a
bone thing going on this is for my wacom
tablet all right
second place
you get all that stuff plus a ricoco
motion capture smartsuit pro 2
mocap suit
from our good friends at ricoco and
if you come in first place you get all
that stuff but instead of just the mocap
suit you get the full motion capture
performance bundle that comes with the
gloves it comes with the pro pro 2 suit
comes with the face cap capture rig it
comes with
their studio
license and all the good stuff you get
all the good stuff so
without further ado let's uh let's
switch over to our guest today y'all
y'all know i don't know who who who's
creeping here
what's up
[Laughter]
freddy yes
dude thank you thank you so much for
doing this i'm i'm coming at you live
from a slightly smokier room my room's a
little foggier you can see that the
the shadows are a little milked out
that's because i got my fog machine
running 24 7. i have just as cool set up
as you but i have a fog machine
so
you know that's that's the way to step
it up that is the way to step it up
y'all if you guys don't
know
about the legend
freddy wong
let me let me tell you a little bit
about freddie wong so
on the channel we bring
we try to bring
educators teachers but mainly friends
here freddie and
you are like the first person you are
literally the first person it was
because of you i moved out to la we've
been over this right we know that yeah
that was a bad decision
you were like
you're like clint drop out of
college drop out become a
take that college degree and just burn
it you'll hear it your dad said no let
me talk to him put him on the phone
put your dad on
yeah i talked to you did that's right i
talked to your dad yeah like hey it's
cool
you're like i'm not just some random
internet dude like you gotta trust i am
no
i was like actually that's how it
started as a i am some random internet
dude but listen
i mean dude i
i was a fan of of your stuff from the
very beginning so if you guys don't know
freddie
he started out look like i mean he's
before youtube right that we don't need
to get into before before youtube but
freddie was like the first guy to
start doing these vfx short films every
week
kind of videos and he you know freddie
you paved the way for so much of us to
to create cool vfx action comedy stuff
online and yeah i'd like to apologize
for getting everybody into this
soul-sucking industry like just in
advance
dude you said it you said it best you
were like i wouldn't have got into this
if i didn't know that like i couldn't
sleep in you could get up so early to
film and just i'd rather say that yeah
yeah i would have gotten dude if i had
known that like regular camera
filmmaking required you to get up
because the sun is important it turns
out um guess what i would have probably
learned more
3d that's fair dude i'll spend more time
in 3d
that is very fair i can go sleep
whenever you want when you're working in
3d like you gotta remember that
you were you were like the master you
fall asleep at any point and it was like
it turns out that's sleep apnea oh
that's not superpower that was a medical
condition
we were over there like just like dang
freddie's asleep at his desk like
wow he could just knock out any point
and then like we were playing settlers
of katana and then
i remember we like asked for some rule
it was like me casey and ali like the
first time they came to la and we were
like what is this rule and you're like
he was like this very specific answer
and you're like he's right and he went
back to sleep i was like what
i don't remember this at all exactly
because you were asleep
oh my god that's so hilarious but it was
you and uh and sam and nico samuel nico
started out um you know as as you guys
know from corridor right brandon too
brandon too brandon too yeah yeah it was
like all of you guys were in the
warehouse
in a warehouse yeah yeah sleeping in the
same room together
yeah i remember everyone's everyone
everyone was always like wow so cool you
guys are just huge youtube guys i'm like
nobody nobody was no cameras were
rolling for the
the janky part of the career
jimmy jimmy told you or told me how he
trained you not to snore
yeah he would kick me
he you guys would sleep opposite right
yeah yeah yeah yeah so we would we had a
bunk bed but the top bunk was for
storage we need a little tiny room and
so me and jimmy shared a twin bunk bed
for like a year and a half this was i'd
graduate college i had a degree
like it was some hard time like at the
time it didn't seem janky at the time it
was like oh this is so cool it's so fun
me and my bro just sleeping you know toe
to head and then like later like i tell
people about that and they're like what
you were in your what
i was like yeah i guess like looking
back at it that does seem
but like you know what whatever it's
funny you can do what you got to do you
do what you got to do like you guys were
you said you were open in the oven for
for heat at some point
winter time it was straight up i
remember like sam and niko would be like
yo get some renders going let's get our
gpus like going it's too cold in here
and they would like to just be like you
know i mean
that's that's those are some desperate
times but like y'all did it those are
desperate times but you know what it was
good times it was good times i would
have traded it for the world some grand
wild times it was so much fun it's the
best yes and he came down and joined us
and then i don't know if people know
this that clint joined us and then
clint became one of the best trials
players in the world
oh god the trump trials that no people
don't
so
you know the video game the the like we
got the thing where it was like me matt
and clint were like oh let's play like
the extreme mode and we're going and
then like matt and i like kind of
dropped off but clint kept going one day
we'd go over to where where clint was
and we're like where's clint he was
sitting there just like
like i hadn't moved
he didn't move and he was like clint was
like punching if you look at those
leaderboards i'm like i forgot what it
was punisher had some top what was your
top like how high did you it was uh so
for those of you who know trials this is
session i'm talking to one person right
now um
it was like inferno three i think i made
it to like second place or something
second place yeah in the world yeah in
the world
it was bad
it was bad dude it was the greatest
dedication you need though you know it's
true man it's true like concentration
that focus i remember like the first
time i came to la with you guys and
and we all got together and i met sam
and nico and i met brandon and yourself
and i met jimmy and like there's
probably some other people in there but
like
i just remember spending a week building
that inverted pyramid in minecraft we
were all playing minecraft it was
minecraft alpha this was even before
this is alphabet time so we were like yo
this game is really fun
and we were playing it and then like it
was like right before e3 you were in
town for like e3 and then we're like we
woke up one day and clint was just on
the computer i'm like clint did you go
to sleep he's like no but check this out
and you had like dug out an inverted
pyramid in minecraft like all night i
was like
yeah like it was me and jimmy we built
it out and then jimmy's like right i'm
going to bed keep it up and i was like i
got you i'll work through the night and
then like late
it's so stupid it was like
what what is this
there's a lot of shenanigans man um
those are some of the best best times
just some good times just some good
times but we're here to look at some cg
absolutely absolutely i can't wait i'm
really excited to look at this cg we've
come a long way um
and and now is the time
to look at these top 100 renders so let
me get let me get davinci cued up here
let me get this okay let me get the uh
thing going all right so
let me hide this clip we're gonna pop
this
off
all right
i don't think anything else needs to be
said so we're gonna we're gonna go
through a hundred clips okay
we're gonna go through 100 clips
everyone get comfortable get beverage go
to the bathroom
absolutely clips it's going to be a good
time
um we're going to get through all 100
and then i'm going to come back around
and announce
the top five winners all right um maybe
the top five is going to be in sprinkled
in this right yes
somewhere ah yes yes exactly
um and then anything else anything else
yeah if you see your art you're getting
that kickbash kit so congrats to you
styles morales thanks for the super chat
i see you i see you thank you guys for
joining me 2400
people up in the live chat
let's do it starting
uh the first of the first we got
zoom in here
nathaniel
yes
hotkeys
hotkeys nathaniel
amazing little hitch little hitchcock
zoom in there oh yeah you know what
oh a little hitchcock zoom and it's
catching some uh catching some some
light rays as it as it goes that's
that's uh that's a little detail so
because the camera's physically moving
back and it's catching a little
yeah so basically the hitchcock zoom was
built in to the
the prop the template file right so they
had
uh to choose between 27 animations
and
our boy nathaniel here is crushing it
really nice forest scene good god rays
like you mentioned
love the animation on the tassels the
physics on it
yup
yup good sim
yeah
just really flowy cloth i love it yeah
it's a beautiful scene nice and buttery
they got some diffusion going too
uh very peaceful
very good stuff nathaniel congrats to
you
for making that top 100 a lot of people
aim for that top 100 um but only point
two seven people make it
if you let the temple know that uh one
of those uh lanterns a little bit of
skew
and some some monks gotta come in with a
shovel and like you know get it back up
to
absolutely dude
crucial
crucial limb though now
all right
next up
who do we got next we got
galen
[Music]
turtles
[Laughter]
yeah oh this one's hilarious
so good they really captured the vibe i
feel like when we were go so i was going
through all of these renders with my
moderators and i think it was visual who
said
this could easily be super janky but
they did a really good job here it looks
amazing it's animated well
um
there's not any awkward stretching it
feels pretty darn natural and
dude they're killing it they're crushing
it like they got video games on the left
they got computers on the right
it's a good time
i love how the i love how it's the
old-school like turtle like the original
turtles design right like it looks
closer to the original uh
turtle's design which i dig absolutely
yeah absolutely
really nice with the like
oh go ahead yeah i'm just saying of
course michelangelo's got some pizza
there just some real real attention to
detail you know what i mean
mike's the one mike's the one on the nes
with the zaha like come on
absolutely crucial
uh nice volumetric little uh light shaft
here
from the uh from that little light top
light there and
yeah just solid overall really solid
details nice bloom nice glow galen
congratulations to you for making top
100 hats off to you
graffiti too yeah just fantastic good
attention to detail
all right next up we have
jaeger
you go
nice
yup
oh my gosh it's ever it's everyone it's
the whole cake the whole gang is here
yep
so good
the lighting is perfect it's a lot the
lighting is really what
because everybody's getting this great
edge lighting right like it just pops
all the characters out in a way
that
oh unless you cut every time it loops
you've got something else you could look
at i love it absolutely it's just like
the air particles little butterfly
there's a little butterfly that lands on
his left little ear it's
wow
so good there's a b on the bottom right
butterflies
um the subsurface scattering is looking
beautiful the colors are so saturated
it's a really really nice render is he
adding a little mouth for finn little
that's so good yeah it's beautiful uh
jaeger
jagor
congratulations to you this is really
nice yeah keep it up man you're killing
it killing it
all right
next up
who's next
who's next
it's paul
our boy paul
oh wow paul's one of the ogs on the
server
constantly doing weekly challenges here
built out this room
some very nice lighting coming in from
the side
mix of color temperatures too is very
interesting right you have the warmth
your your sunlight is pushing warm but
you're also going like cool with the
interior like it looks like led lights
almost right totally
so they got a little simu glove on the
left there
my boy simu from his stock photo days
that's great
yeah this is really good stuff paul good
attention to the detail of the books on
the right posters in the back video
games
um it's just a it's just a solid scene
you wanna know my favorite little detail
here tell me it's on the right side you
see the wind there's window light right
yeah they're not right it looks like
there's like a doubled up pane of glass
versus a sing you know what i'm saying
looks like the wind is open so it's so
one is a little warmer like that's a
very subtle attention to detail thing
right holy crap
yeah i like that i like that oh we would
actually you know what it might be is
actually the light passing through the
curtains there
there's one on the there's you get the
curtain but i think it's a i think it's
implying the window itself is open oh no
you are right because that curtain is
drawn it's back
and you and you do get that curtain each
of those panels are three separate
things which is just a real real subtle
attention to detail that's great
little black cat in there too very nice
good stuff paul congratulations to you
for making top 100
kit bash kits for everyone
all right
alejandro
alejandro is next
what you got alejandro
oh little robot with some moss on it
doing some work here oh yeah
it looks like when you when the robo
does a little force push a little grass
reacts too
just oh yeah you're right look at that
yeah like a little gust of wind almost
oh great
yeah really nice here a good wind it's
like you can tell so much when you don't
have wind with grass and foliage it just
looks so
stock you know that's true it almost
feels like if you're gonna do grass you
have to make it a little windy
even though like i've i've been to parks
it's not windy all the time
no absolutely not you'd be like oh my
god what's happening but like when
you're doing 3d you know you
you want to kind of push things beyond
real and the same same for movies too
right you want to push it beyond to like
what you think it should look like what
it would look like if it was like the
best version of
wherever you're at
little eyes a little is he blinking at
me at the end there yeah
a boy's blinking at me
[Music]
activated
yeah very nice alejandro very good stuff
congratulations for that top 100 keep it
up loving these mossy robots
all right freddie this one this next
one's interesting
okay
[Music]
that's so clever i love it
yeah
there's a lot of there's there's
actually been a lot of these kind of
stop-motiony
um
it's all about the armature switching
sides and stuff that's so funny that's
actually the first time someone's done
the armature thing a lot of people have
done the stop-motion but having the
armature in is is a new one yeah like
you've definitely seen those you
actually know that right you really need
to know those videos to be able to know
that oh yeah sometimes the armature is
just jumping around all over the place
i'm so tempted to pull the key on this
too and like put something in the
background
yeah yeah oh that's hilarious
yeah very very like it's a very simple
foreground you know um
you know it's a set so
here's but here's the thing that's
really cool about it is that you get the
sense that it's a miniature right the
texture scale
makes it feel like you're not looking at
it
it makes it feel like you're looking at
a small seed yeah especially the wood on
the left especially at the little like
it look it looks like a little porcelain
or not pores like a a stone where you
know me like teacup instead you know for
the thing it's just like you actually it
actually feels like a miniature which is
cool yeah
very good attention to detail on that
yeah if you go any more detailed then it
kind of isn't good for the scene you
know so
uh who's this caleb you did a fantastic
job
building this out so congrats to you top
100 baby let's go love it
yes
all right who's next
eric oh
dramatic
whoa
yes
wow
yeah this one's awesome i love the
lighting here and the lighting it really
gets me here colors the clip what's
happening
so good wow
the llama like
breaks out of its
shell
so cool yeah
yeah and it's you know and look it's
it's smart to build in right what what
other variation what other sort of you
know arc can you build into these and
smart to be like well let's take a look
at lighting and how that can change
right how there's a solar eclipse
happening and you know there's other
stuff you can throw at
yeah a lot of these people um they did a
really good job and as we'll see
picking animations that had a big like
action moment like this there's a
handful of them right and then they'd
affect the environment the lighting
different simulations to to reflect that
energy and you'll we'll see there's some
really insane ones
but eric man i love this i really really
dig this your lighting is very
interesting i love the silhouette at the
beginning and
very moody
um
little side lights coming in i dig it
congratulations
very cool
go ahead because right like the the
lighting at the beginning right you're
doing this really hard backlight and
then it's like okay then afterwards
you're adding that all in right because
it's identical it would be the identical
situation turns the backlight but it's
like yeah shows you kind of what you get
when you
work the fill into it and using that as
a way of differentiating the beginning
at the end yeah
yeah nice to justify the light change
with the move too
um
all right who's next we got moween
oh dude this one is this one is crazy
oh
okay so
i reversed this like
i might just do it right now just to
show you
yeah yeah but
it's because i was like oh they just
like reversed you know
did
the
salmon reversed it back right yeah not
what happened so
yes and no so i i did that right i'll do
it right now
okay this is this is mauine
uh let's reverse
and
play
so you're like wait a second oh wait a
minute right it's like the the big
pieces feel like they're
very deliberate
the big pieces are going forward now but
the water is going backwards
oh my gosh wow he's blending a lot yeah
so that means that
he like
simmed the destruction like this like
we're seeing it now yeah
and then i'll undo this
but they did had the water react to the
sim to the reverse yeah that's cool
that's super cool
yeah
yeah this is amazing mowing awesome sim
like it's all about the sim here but
your lighting is great too and your your
environment is super sick
that is a little you know um
everyone people work hard on those
columns you know i'm just saying that
this this you know this being just kind
of casually destroying this you know
like i'll know about that but you know
what it looks cool
yeah
there's archaeologists around the world
being like no
just heart attacks all just passed at
the same time r.i.p all the
archaeologists watching this one tuning
into this stream we're sorry this is
just you know what the problem is
destruction is cool in 3d so sorry nerds
it looks so sick yes mowing
congratulations to you
very cool yeah
um good stuff good stuff all right
moving on we got uh
night
lazy
this one's beautiful
i just want to be here
you know this reminds me of like a smash
bros level or like a tekken level or
something or something it does it does
have tekken level vibes dude
when's tekken gonna have this get this
splashing around in the pool level dude
they might you know who knows dude who
knows when's the last time you played
tekken dude it's been
ages uh pizza party after my soccer team
didn't win anything
brutal
i i got a i got a trophy that said i was
in the right place at the right time but
no one passed to me so you know what
you know everybody wins you know
everyone
got some birds there in the top top left
there just sort of easily making their
way little birdos there's a i guess
there's a little little pop in the sim
here on the left but that's fine it's
all good your scene is absolutely
beautiful top 100 baby
uh mo no this is not me this is night
night lazy yeah i dig the scene i want
to be here um i love like the misty
water you got going in the background i
think that's really nice well it's also
the stone animals too right it's like
it's kind of they they're really well
aged making it look like you know it's
just just a moist environment a real
moist environment
absolutely
absolutely
yeah i dig it
sweet
good stuff night
is there an award for moist this
environment are you gonna do that one we
could do that on the next one
just have it just like whoever's got the
wettest sip
god
weird submissions this time we do the
top 100 from bathtubs
perfect
all right who's next
alexi
[Laughter]
i love this one
i love the little reaction of the bunny
being like y'all seeing this you see
these smooth moves
yeah just like look over just to confirm
that like this is happening right now
right
it's just the bunny no one's giving him
nobody's giving the bunny what for dang
this is so cute the the lighting the way
you kind of
turn the environment on here it's
perfect having the character being
spotlit from this window everything else
is dark it draws the attention of the
character yeah cool evolution of
lighting on that yeah good particles
good atmosphere um really nice
environment well thought out
well designed um
it's so wild to me what you can
accomplish just solo these days right
like dude
we we were alive at a time when like a
little scene like this would be what a
team of people having to like all be you
know it's just wild i love it dude look
at the bear in the back in the chair
what
what there's a bear in the back there's
a bear on the chair in the back i never
knew that
bro
can you see it like barely it's got
really spooky now i gotta say
dude i got i got chills dude papa bear
while we were watching
we were being watched this whole time
dude think about that
[Laughter]
super spooky
that is actually terrifying
yeah this is solid alexi congratulations
um
dophnut uh
thank you for the super chat finally
made your first unreal project because
of this challenge that is what's up
way to get started heck yeah keep it up
there will be more challenges
right not
all right jonas walter
what do you have for us today
the subsurface scattering
on your textures
on your shaders rather
are beautiful
yeah
kelp town dude
the background oh yeah yeah the
background and then like the little
uh
root structure that then shows up mm-hmm
it's also not even at once it actually
draws your eye
right to left right it goes out and then
kind of sweeps out around it's like
there's just a lot of eye movement when
you see it it's a lot of objects that
are catching your eye and moving them
around like for me
the particles go in it hits the center
you see it go out and i go down to the
bottom left right and then i kind of
come back around it's just
your eye takes this like arc through it
which is really cool yeah a really nice
reveal really nice evolution of your
environment i also dig these like night
market potato chip looking things on the
right night market potato chip you know
the spiral you know that like potato
chip spiral at the night market i love
the potato spiral oh
dude so good fresh potato spiral um
i don't know like what this like cabbage
town i don't know what this looks like
but it looks sick i dig it um it's
talking under watery kind of vibes
yeah cool character too
good stuff jonas
killing it congratulations to you um
benoit
maybe i said that right
maybe yeah actually
this one's this one's great i love it's
a definitely more of a cartoony style um
which i didn't do which i dig
through the lip top lips
some character on it i know that's how
that's how you know you're concentrating
dude okay
kim is gonna kill me
for telling this story
[Laughter]
during a piano recital
she was so focused that her she like
that was that was her in the background
right here the tongue was out and
focused on the piano so hard
it's true that's just listen you know
what michael jordan did the same thing
you know what i'm saying
[Music]
i believe it i believe it but yeah i dig
this one it's super cool i love the
colors i love the lighting um it feels
like a show i would watch actually and
it's like it's crazy because so many of
these renders like maybe not in the top
100
because i try and pick like a nice
variety but
a lot of the artists
go for a realistic photo reel kind of
look and that's a very hard
thing to hit you know you you either get
there or you don't
and it takes
so much to get there um have you ever
gotten one that was just like a ps2
render just like hard ps2 vibes
trying to think in top 100 potentially
yes uh but the all renders like out of
all the renders absolutely yeah yeah
yeah i love that i love it so much it's
very necessary i never submit it's just
gonna be like straight up n64 vibes heck
yeah the video's gonna come at you it's
128 by 128 i can't even i gotta resize
this you're disqualified i'm like nah
but the ncc4 though
i love that vibe it's a very nostalgic
vibe
yeah this is awesome good render good
candle good candle light too yeah nice
flame flicker yeah yeah probably what a
cloth sim uh
with some emissive action going good
stuff benoit
benoit
it's probably benoit yeah
um
top 100 baby let's go who's next
who is next
this one's sick i love the lighting here
and
who knows if it's uh
like um
what is it goes to tsushima inspired but
it feels like that whaling town um but
it's it's got vikings
so what's cool about what's cool about
this one is like i feel like you can
almost even though there's no sound to
it you almost like hear a soundtrack
to it right like there's a something
about the quality of the of the move
motion the movement that the sort of way
that the portal opens up you've kind of
like internally in the back of your head
like you're applying your own soundtrack
to it
sound effects right ramps up slowly
nice
yeah there's a rhythm to it
oh so good
so good rendered very nicely i'd be
curious to
find out what renderer they used for
this because there's a handful of
renders that
look like this like the renderer itself
looks very cinematic
they added grain here which is always a
clutch move
um
but it has a softness to it yeah also i
love that for a second you can see a
figure in the smoke right there right it
feels like it may just be you know
oh where side effect right so like right
there there's like this like bird-like
sort of thing that seems to come out of
the smoke like your mind is
right there you see this sort of like it
may just be the sim but like it i don't
know this that's what i see it just
gives it
a second of character in shape are you
sure about the bird that is literally
flying no no no no above him right there
well like a freaking dementor
yeah dude straight up dementors all up
in here dude
freaking awesome
yeah very good stuff guys guys on the
boat are like yeah that's just yorkson
doing his thing on the beach
he's like
that's me that's me in the boat being
like hey we're going what are you doing
here
we're back in here dude you've been at
it for hours
we're done
we're finished
we're done let's go
uh who's this enrico enrico
congratulations for top 100 love your
render love your lighting
love the whole vibe love your sim man
very good stuff
i put you in a very specific point in
the in the compilation too
uh when the music dips down so
um i'm gonna do a little little bit of
sound design
on these next couple renders to really
kind of like
change the tone before we get back into
the jams
um
can't wait cannot wait next week is top
100 um the music is almost done so it's
gonna be awesome all right moving on
hemming
hemming you
oh it's like it's almost like um like
waterfall mist coming down
yeah
yeah super cool
i dig this those situations it's very
bad if you have glasses because you
can't see
dude
[Laughter]
yosemite we uh yosemite falls man it was
just the worst i mean like it's really
blurry
yeah you're like i'm just trying to get
out of this waterfall please
you know what this really gets this gets
me more than any submission so far i
feel cold right this this somehow what i
love sometimes is when you can get an
ineffable quality from you know a cg
render and like i get such a feeling of
like chilliness from this that don't you
absolutely it's the color temperature
it's the mist coming in it's like i feel
like a little i feel like it's cold this
just feels cold to me
yeah and in the clothing too like it's
yeah it's just like that it's like i
can't put a figure a lot i just i'm like
this feels cold i feel cold when i look
at this which is like very cool yeah
absolutely i'm going to do some like
nice cold wind sound effects on this one
that's going to are you going to design
all of them huh heck no i okay so
absolutely not
um
on only one of the challenges this is
the fifth challenge but only one of them
we've required sound um
that was the marble one i believe
oh yeah yeah that's cool since then a
lot of people have done sound even
though it's not required but i do cut
everything there's no sound no sound is
is uh taking into account when judging
or anything um right right but there's
moments in the music where the music
dips and i and i want to bring that kind
of cinematic value to it so for that
quality to it so i'll i'll sound as in a
couple like chill chiller moments like
this one in the next couple renders yeah
yeah yeah cool good stuff having you
good animation on the uh on the grass
there what would have been jank if there
was no grass wind
andrew
love this one
love this one
how cool
that's me by the way on the left just
chilling just vibes dude porca stock
porgo rosso vibes on the left
oh this i love the story that this has
in it right it's like
there's such an implication of
toxic waste with nuclear waste wasteland
cockroaches but it's like all just in
the background details
i wish like i think this is one where i
want to see a little more of the
environment actually like it was just a
little bit environment that's cool i
like the silhouettes of the the phone
lines all being askew you know just sort
of adds this wasteland quality little
mushrooms growing out little fungi
growing out of the skull
is there there's a dude watching there's
a cockroach watching from the skull bro
oh he's waving
he's waving bro he's just chilling he's
chilling over there dude trying to draw
attention away from his good bud doing
tai chi dude hey hey
oh that's probably oh man that's awesome
there's a little cockroach on the top
right too walking along that stick
yeah
set this up
so good so good this makes me want to
play fallout 3 again dude
that's like the oldest reference um very
good stuff very good stuff andrew i love
how unique this is your unique character
beautiful lighting beautiful composition
you're knocking out the park congrats on
top 100 baby
yes so there's gotta be more right the
mocap doesn't have six arms
no it does not so they did a really good
job a little extra a little extra on
there
maybe some hand animation probably yeah
very good stuff
all right who's next
another andrew
does this make you feel like you're in
toronto
i okay yes it was toronto i was like
trying to like literally the building on
the left made me feel like
korea okay but this has
hard canada vibes
from canada is the person from canada
you know we weren't asking their country
on this one so i don't know
but maybe if they're in the chat
i feel canada vibes yeah i don't know
why like look at the trees in the back
dude
this is sort of a voxel character in the
front here right yeah super cool
dig it voxel character with some good
kicks
absolutely
i love that there's like
this blend of technology you still have
like a rail like cram and but you still
all do you also have flying cars you
know what i mean
yeah it's a slow transition you know
yeah listen it's not listen overnight we
don't get flying cars overnight by the
way we do have flying cars they're
called helicopters
[Laughter]
like well
helicopters are just flying cars you
have you need a license you can go
anywhere you want basically basically
only rich people use them these all
sound like things flying cars would be
true before so
that's a that's very that's very thought
about it that way
i'm glad you're here okay someone point
this out
it
who's driving the bus blender the
company
yeah that's what it looks like
what the heck automated blender dude
blender's driving that bus dude they
broke that blender yeah urban dust pearl
got blender in the bus dude
you got a little monkey in the trash can
on the right too
i love the details and all
right just stare at them and find little
things
see i know i know it's so good
so good i love the lighting here the
little uh
little sim in the beginning the closet
in the beginning with the paper is
awesome uh your traffic in the
background
uh it looks like you're doing
some interesting like automated uh
position
noise movements uh situation for those
lights in the back because you chose the
right colors the red tail lights and
like the warm
headlights
um they're moving like
well fireflies yeah like little
fireflies they're on that just on that
flat plane it's like curved road it's
definitely a curved road then see but
yeah interesting oh and they are ripping
too they're going
ripping dude it's the future dude you'll
drive slow in the future unless it's
public transit
oh good stuff good stuff andrew she
should be in the crowd she should be in
the crosswalk though you see behind her
there's a crosswalk if you're gonna be
doing stuff in the street everybody do
it in the crosswalk okay honestly that's
a really good point because
this is unsafe no but for real cause
like what you gotta think like one of
the big challenges of these renders is
why is your character doing tai chi like
what are the
what are they doing why are they doing
it
and to do it in the middle of the road
like this you might be like okay
maybe get in that crosswalk maybe that
would be a little bit more justified
maybe hit the button get in the
crosswalk first you know let the traffic
know i mean you see how fast these cars
are driving this is dangerous absolutely
but wait there's
there's like an oil spill with some like
cones here so maybe that road is closed
who knows
who knows
it doesn't matter though they got this
hovering blender's driving the bus
they're hovering to their destination
good to see that neon under lights keep
with it in the future yeah it's a five
it's five it's a five who's next
who is next
this one dude
whoa
bro i got a whole day night cycle dude
this is absurd
i'll let this play through a couple more
times and i'm going to reframe my friend
because there's some cool stuff going on
um ow oh the person's dropping a piece
of trash and coming and picking it up
yup oh my goodness all right so
basically what we have here
there's a lot of stuff going on um
this is
i don't think anyone's any ever done a
render like this they've done
stop-motion ones but they hadn't done
one over like a day time lapse a little
focus pull in the middle because the
camera was on auto
dude in the way of the camera this for
his gram just for the gram and just to
ruin the shot
that's attention to detail
because there's idiots who are going to
ruin your shot dude these guys heckling
his photos at least the robots aren't
messing the shot up though that's true
dude this is like buckingham palace
vibes a person's trying to get them off
of their vibe dude little trash can
it's like a trash bot that picks it up
yeah
oh and he doesn't go for it right away
he sees it oh my god that's so cool
trashbot's also moving slow too
yeah about that that means there needs
to be a blend right if you want to catch
those details in order for that to work
right like this trashbot has to be
moving real slow right this was a real
thing so you're thinking about like oh
some things are going that like you know
blurry background but what what what
what a thing to know this right all the
characters are moving fast but it's like
no the trashbot needs to be moving slow
too so there is still in focus as well
right yeah absolutely and like even like
the way they
i don't know if it's just me but like
the way they crouch over is like an
older korean woman or something it's
just like uh you know pick up some trash
the posing yeah they're losing to the
weight that's really good it looks like
an old it feels like an old woman um the
way they move
it kind of justifies the fact that
they're going slow wait it feels like
you have weight there and then like
what's cool is you contrast also the
posing of these you know these crash
test dummy looking robots which is very
upright and rigid which even the posing
is different for the humans which are a
little more bendy a little more slouched
over right there's a guy in the hoodie
there's a little more slouch just like
wow yeah
so much attention to detail and there's
like birds landing on her and stuff
on her head and
yeah this is crazy he did such a good
job too
yeah this is anna
you did such a good job of
blending the two environments like the
lighting always looks good
yeah wow so nice i love this night i
would love to see a loop of this
actually you should have kept going it
gets windier and it's windier at night
too just like real life bro you can see
the
stuff through the flag oh
wow she opens her eyes at the end too
that's crazy
yeah
yeah oh my goodness good stuff anna my
goodness amazing
here's another one for you
complete opposite
yes
[Laughter]
that's so good yeah that was a little
nice little added remix there so good
you're the laptop you got that you got
the laptop
adjusting the screen on the laptop over
time oh wow mm-hmm camera on the right
and check this out they actually
look at their hands they're green screen
oh assistant oh yeah
clever really clever really clever
yeah very very very well done
i love that this is actually two shots
right you have the shot that we're
seeing but the shot that's being wait
what's right there's a little camera on
the right that's also getting it
probably the shot itself right or oh my
god
well yeah you're right so you on the
left you got like the the 3d program on
the right you have the actual it's
getting the shot itself but dude look at
the shadow of his hand that's not
they had to add that in 3d like that's a
3d card that is that is casting a shadow
on the wall
of the kitchen because his hands are
comped in right so there's no way that
shadow will be cast so he's coming in
and he's adding shadows for his content
oh my god
dude i gotta say though bojack his abs
are like it's really there's so much
abdominal muscle going on here
like not accurately
i mean i'm just i mean like that's a
horse man so it's already in the world
of not accurate but like
those abs dude you could crunch for days
i see it yeah i see it did you watch the
show i'm not i haven't seen it yeah yeah
oh it's a great show here it's good yeah
yeah this is awesome oh we got a little
oh it's cool you see the table how
there's wires that come down when it's
in between in the flip phase
oh my god
there's little wires and strings as if
it's like flipped right like oh wow and
he's touching them too to like
dang
key real karil is the person's name
amazing amazing you gotta have them
submit their names with a pronunciation
guide
that's actually the phonetic
pronunciation yeah just like
phonetically how do i say your name so
they'll butcher it on stream sorry it's
hilarious
wow congrats top 100 baby
so good so so good
this one yes
[Music]
right here this
that face punch on the left is amazing
i love that one guy who's just piecing
out on the right he sees his friend get
clocked he's like i'm done
if i see you get backhanded by a foot
like that i'm not running away i would
be like yo take a camera out dude
take a camera that's even worse
oh i love it i love the oh yeah the
character designs yeah i was gonna say
like there's like the gang
the pig gang
and then you know this dude and his wife
was just trying to get to work
and there's like the tag on the right
story here the story here a very
japanese um subway too because you know
they have those q stickers right most of
the time oh my god you're gonna put it
this way there's none of that courtesy
in the usa tell you that much
you're right and look they're actually
little pig hoofs
instead of feet oh really oh my god
you're right that's great
yeah
that's great
it's all those little world building
details that i love every time you can
get a chance yeah you're right they
would need to queue up but like that
wouldn't be human feet it wouldn't be
right that's great
[Music]
i love this vibe dude that just reminds
me okay so
when we we went to japan together uh
maybe five years ago i don't know maybe
six it was our first time to japan
and
it was myself jimmy
sam and kevin and we were all
going there to
you know
eating at jiro's son's place was on the
list right
yeah and
freddie you got word of this you're like
dude
you guys are going to cheer us like put
me down for an extra extra person i will
be there it's the most extra i've ever
been which is i flew to japan to get
sushi
dude it was uh
it was that's a separate story the book
is so good
so we
we get to japan early right i think we
get there a couple days beforehand
freddie you or you know you're doing
things busy doing some stuff you were
going to meet us there a couple days
later
and
uh
we plan to meet in the busiest
train station shinjuku station that's
right yeah the biggest train station the
busiest train station in the world
and
we we were like where is freddy where is
freddy we're looking around we're
looking around this place is packed this
rush hour people are just getting
cramped i blend in you know what i'm
saying
right
redhead i've got anime hair i'm blended
in people are like people are going
about their their day business suits
looking nice um it's like maybe 10
o'clock and all of a sudden we're like
trying to find freddy
we look and just in the middle of this
super busy crowd like that last render
we just see freddy on his phone just
looking around just like within in your
flip-flops in the busiest train station
in the world like oh there's freddie
those are freddy
[Laughter]
it was so weird dude it was so surreal
oh hey what's up guys i gotta say on
this animation really quick the pig on
the right who does the flying like backs
back kick yeah he's going for his friend
yeah
you know what i'm saying those guys have
beef or pork
yeah
that's rough very cool though very cool
good stuff
pinaro
amazing work amazing work tomorrow
congrats on top 100.
gavin's next with the matrix the matrix
a little more facial hair dude i know
right it's not neo i don't think it's
neo it's like it's his uh it's his like
cousin
yeah
like b-b-o b-o
it smells bad too
a little time freeze dude catching drops
yeah good stuff really really nice
attention to detail there beautiful
environment beautiful lighting um looks
like
kit bash buildings
i think it's kit bash buildings hard to
say
um but
yeah i dig the overall vibe
diggy atmosphere
oh that's cool look at that look at the
droplets and how they affect
the reflection in the slow-mo right it's
not just a clean right there's a wri the
ripple of it it's just uh it's really
cool on the reflection on the uh
throttle in front of them yeah look at
the reflection of the puddle as it goes
in the slow-mo
of the background like lighting you know
what i'm saying like it's like
you can see the yeah it's just like the
ripples just slows down everything just
slows down for a second oh wow
yeah it's really well done great good
good job having the birds too
it's like okay it's definitely slow-mo
we got the birds
got it hit that jaw will move you know
john would knows you don't ever see a
burdens level before john was like just
throw him at the camera done
[Laughter]
perfect
good stuff gavin congrats to you lovely
color correct love the lighting
solid scene man
uh lee
his next lease song
a little uh bakery cafe made cafe bakery
situation someone's birthday
turning this move into a teapot right
yeah it's so clever it's like you know
right
yeah there's a lot of a lot of
interesting uses of the mocap i love how
the tea is like flops out of the things
like yeah some tea for you
so much so much baked goods here
yeah it's incredible
if i do wonder i do wonder how do robots
eat baked goods you know that's a great
question suck it right into their chests
but like a lot of little background
details the balloons the color scheme
it's the kind of place where i'm like if
you told me that like yeah this is like
this is like a concept render for like a
baked goods place i'd be like yeah it
sounds about right it's in japan
somewhere yeah i got it in france
definitely yeah i feel like if you were
to like whittle down
this
like color scheme
or flavor
okay you you have you have um color
scheme slash flavor
uh
what is the flavor
that you see oh this is like too sweet
this is like cotton candy for me okay
yeah i'm saying like this like i put
this you put this image in your mouth
and it dissolves way too fast it's very
sugary yeah it's a blast i don't say
birthday cake so it's pretty close
birthday cake yeah it's the confetti i
don't know why but the confetti mix
pushes it towards a birthday cake
territory definitely
good stuff lee congrats on talking
i can't explain why these i can't
explain why some of these renders taste
the way they do but they do okay you
know what i'm just saying is that
glitter baby it's that glitter so nice
good stuff lee congrats
oh this one's awesome
the chickens the robo chickens look they
got they got a robo leg and a normal leg
oh wow yeah they all have like different
little pieces of tech on them too
it's so wild it's like what is the what
is the world like right like yeah the
little king's got glowing eyes one
doesn't but
this is this guy's like hey i asked i
asked you can i get a jump
hey
i just wanted to jump
but hey
what i mean
hey
he's back there just like
ah jeez
is this russian what is that up there
that is cyrillic it looks like
what is that
what's the russian russian alphabet okay
yeah i love the lighting here it's
beautiful really nice like bus look at
that
yeah it's it's a good contrast and
balance of light and color tone
because you're bouncing that sunlight
right off that flat
front face of the bus and it it really
balances the image i feel like the bus
wasn't there you're right yeah that
gives you a highlight on the right that
kind of gives you a nice counterpoint to
the highlights coming off of the figure
right it's almost like a separate oh
that's clever yeah
really good stuff yeah igor
love it this also makes me want to play
fallout 3.
[Laughter]
i love the wind so like when they do the
little gravity shift the leaves go up
too
oh yeah you're right now sick
sick
good stuff igor top 100
ennis
is next whoa okay
wow
yeah
kept the dolly zoom too in the actual
like
drawing which is awesome
i love these little scenes here these
realistic ones
um
i will just note just a small thing
but the uh
staedtler lumograph pencils
the black is a little long hold on let's
compare let me get let me get you side
by side here
let's see all right so these are the
statler lumograph pencils that you're
seeing in the back which i love these
pencils these are great pencils
and then
okay yeah
yeah
but
i only noticed that after many many but
like all the rest of it and you know i
love how it evolves too alright like the
background's not there first and then
there's shading and then color comes
into it again it's that telling it's
that evolution of the image over time
that's like really interesting
yeah i dig this one a lot all the
details on the side too like the notes
and everything
they got their their deadline and like
the character concepts they got notes
check boxes it feels very realistic like
a nice workstation i'm sure i'm sure uh
ennis here who made this fringer
does this
you know
a lot of people bring their hobbies into
it so
yeah yeah yeah
good reference
make what you know amazing
that's a huge assumption
but go ahead yeah
well it's like because of that you can
bring certain details into it right it's
like yeah it's going to be an eraser to
me i think so because like it's not a
it's not a standard eraser right on the
left that's like the the artist's eraser
yeah the gummy one yep i'm gummies
super sick good stuff ennis congrats on
top 100 congrats on that kit bash kit
moving on
all right this is our boy uh
uh
who is this i forgot his name he's on
the discord server right of course the
game factory yes
tomas
there's like
i i love the use here of the dolly zoom
to reveal background details yep it's a
it's an extraordinary thing
it's an extra level of depth to the
scene rather than having these elements
in at the beginning right you're like
back here like ah okay there's more to
it it's being filmed
yep it's a solid reveal good good build
of the scene here it's so funny too um
every week we do little uh
little catch-ups on the discord server
where people come up on the stage and
talk about their art and he did he came
up and he was like dude i did a whole
water sim for that thing and it was so
unnecessary it could have just been
great yeah
i love the film scratches to start off
in like the old school japanese like you
know
yeah he's a kurosawa fan
he's going for it
yeah amazing stuff congrats game factory
on top 100 you earned it man really good
stuff
solid solid
okay so this next guy this is russ
etheridge and he does a lot of really
nice tutorials on both skillshare and
youtube um and i've watched his
tutorials a lot and he's killing it look
at this lighting look at
look at the bread
it gets
it gets the commercial lighting feel so
accurately like this feels like food
photography you see in a commercial yeah
this is like postmates waiting for your
order you know yeah yeah you it
literally had it so yeah wow and it's
also too a very clever little detail tip
for me is like the fact that you're
getting that hard reflection in the fork
because it's pointed upwards so you're
like yeah this dude this is a studio lit
environment and the fork even says so
right mm-hmm
that bagel though
yeah that's a pho is that that's a it
feels like a photo of a bagel just sit
it's just so go i know i want to sink my
teeth in it dude dude have you been to
bread lounge
i love bread
okay breadlands is the best they have
the best bagels i've ever had in my life
if you guys are trying to get good
bagels the best videos you've ever had
go to bread lounge downtown la um but
yeah this uh
this is an incredible render it's
beautifully lit it's perfectly colored
like your service is the background
thing to also imply god rays coming from
right like doesn't that imply that the
directionality top down of a sun or
something which is just a very subtle
very cool detail
poor fish too you know just gasping for
air at the top there's just
[Laughter]
brutal dude brutal good stuff russ
thanks for uh for joining the contest
and
hanging out with us man super solid
texture on the on the tomatoes too yeah
it's absurd fingerprints on the knife
it's absurd and the roll on the sardine
the back of the sardine can
it's
ridiculous yeah cool
um all right moving on
moe dude there's this fork and spaghetti
theme right now yup i had to put them
next to each other this one is like
actually disgusting
um
this one's crazy this i'll tell you why
this one creeps me out a little bit it's
the meatball noodles yeah
yeah so good
so i think my favorite thing about this
and it's very subtle which is when the
move comes in and his hands come
together and he draws his hands out
there's a noodle that gets dangled on
his right arm you see that let's see so
his left arm comes in and it moves back
out but there's a noodle that dangles
there and it's like
that's a perfect noodle do you know what
i'm saying like it it it directs your
eye it implies the path of the previous
motion like
i love i don't know why but i absolutely
love that little that's just the
movement of that movement right yeah i
don't know if this is like
i think we can we can always safely
assume blender because um it's free and
it's the it's honestly the majority of
what people are using in these contests
um but
i know c4d came out with a really nice
like rope sim uh as of late
kind of situation so i'm wondering if
that's that um but yeah they look so
nice simulations look so nice especially
attached to like
you know these these pre-animated
characters um yeah i want to be here i
want to eat some spaghetti meatballs
balance your diet out a little bit i'm
just seeing spaghetti apples and ham and
bread what do we do though what are you
about you need some veggies in there
okay i see one bell pepper that's kind
of off in the top right but like i'm
just saying get yourself a salad with
this meal it's a vanity bell pepper too
because it's a heavy meal if you look on
the left i think there's like bell
pepper slices in the plant or something
so they're not even eating them they're
just looking at it you know
you need some vegetables everybody you
need some vegetables in your diet
one interesting blend
yeah seriously
seriously
good stuff good stuff moe
lucas is next
very
very simple
not simple
uh water droplet guy i would say um
i would say what's the word i'm looking
for not simple but uh
god dang it simplistic
yeah i mean yeah there's not a lot
there's not a lot of elements but they
all come together really well i love the
ladybug checking it out being like i'm
good the lady looks perfect
like oh it starts off with this back
legs kind of off as it's floating up you
say i'm saying like right there it's
like it's kind of like
what was that
yeah the subsurface on the vine is nice
you see the light shining through
yeah i think this is
the only
animation like this that made it into
the top 100.
yeah
um maybe there's two i forget but
super solid very simple pretty wet
pretty wet yeah
i'd say so
i'd say so
good film grain good bokeh super solid
stuff
lucas congratulations top 100
what is this
marcus
oh
sorry marcus
so much detail dude
so much detail
oh the little pencil it's got a little
movement on it as well as as the foot
touches
this is how messy my kitchen looks by
the way like yeah i feel i feel very
attacked by this render
you know it's like it's tough when you
got a ton of hobbies you know
i know i know
teapot good teapot
solid yeah i look like incense got some
knives it's such a wealth of textures
too right like you have your organic
plants in the window
not afraid to let that window blow out
and also that leaf blowout too right
just
tiny things that are important that's a
wet leaf dude that is that is like
painted glossy that's a waxy glossy leaf
not i gotta say not as wet as the
previous one this one's not winning any
of the wet categories
oh that's gonna be my soul metric it's
i'm looking for the wettest render
there might be a couple we might go we
might have a couple for you good stuff
marcus congratulations freddie hey um
actually i'm gonna
never mind
moving on
dude
look at the look at the freaking
machine on the left
the machine on the left
there's
so much happening look at the like the
train gears and like the giant engines
dude it's so cool
that machine on the left
that machine on the left almost draws
all your attention to it because it's so
cool yeah
harvester
um
and amazing yeah look at the simulation
here on these plants
on the wheat
wow on the right too you can see like
the harvester in action
so much this seems like a very dangerous
place to be practicing tai chi that's
what i'm saying dude
very dangerous it's kind of wet render
pretty dry pretty dry
very dry this has this has a lot of this
has like um i'll tell you what this one
has for me my allergies are already
pigging off okay i'm sneezing within 30
seconds of this environment
[Laughter]
you walk in there it's like wow this
yeah the particulate there's lots of
particulate you know
yeah a lot of pollen dude
great design
uh really nice um what would you call it
like design on the dress here super cool
i love
i don't know if it's an asset
or if it's handmade but those harvesters
are super cool really beautiful lighting
really good job like
framing up the character here get the
light
in the back kind of kind of silhouetting
them they're side lit but
yeah this is
yeah very very good stuff uh
tamed chaos congratulations to you
all right
one
is next
oh it almost has like a papercraft look
right 100
100 i love the lighting on this one it's
very minimal um
doing yourself a solid by
blocking the background
with that wall so you don't have to like
build stuff out into the background you
just cut it off right there put some
trees mountains done
yeah and then a little focus point yeah
it's like and even the scale feels right
too it's like a little papercraft scene
the muscles in the character too like
the
the paper is chosen correctly it's
designed the character is designed
correctly to like accentuate the muscles
with these different muscles are out of
control oh yeah like look oh my god
just text look back just never skip back
day dude ever
the arch too has that segmentation which
i really like i know
it makes me want to start building stuff
good stuff fun folding dude just better
get to work
you get to work folding it feels like
even the bone size as opposed to like a
full right like the scales are just
really cool yeah the um there's a nice
little ripple little water ripple wave
too that's exactly what i was going to
say yup yeah
very well done looks like they're
cheating it too it's no sim but like
they're doing some sort of deformation
totally gets it across good stuff
amazing so you can cheat for the small
details you know what i'm saying
absolutely
knows if no one knows you're good
andrew
andrew
oh that's oh it's like you're it's like
a it's like a little vr environment
where this person's doing tai chi this
person's the one controlling the
previous one
that's great that's so good i never
caught that actually at first i just got
a little booth
super cool
i love the curved path that the cart
takes right very kowloon walled city
vibes in the back right oh yeah sort of
but like you you'd expect the traffic to
go left to right straight but the fact
that it kind of does this almost roller
coaster curve implies
so much right like there's an
implication there in terms of like what
even this world is and what it looks
like and how these you know things go
you're like oh it must oh it's not on a
road so it's floating right it's like
just a little tiny background detail
that gives you that
like we're operating on multiple levels
here
sorry oh you're good yeah this is this
is an amazing amazing render beautiful
scene very ian hubert um
who's definitely the master of this kind
of vibe here um i don't think this
render would exist without our boy ian
hubert
um but you're killing it i love the red
green contrast super solid
yeah it's very hard to make red green
not feel like christmas oh dude i think
that and i think that like the fact that
it's pushing that you know that this
person's pushing a little more magenta a
little more pink into it and i'm seeing
it on the left overall feels like a
little more magenta that helps it helps
a lot absolutely yeah absolutely yeah
generally when you do red green which is
you know contrasting collagen it's like
the thing you're the whole time you're
just like don't make it look like
christmas don't make it look like
christmas yup
it's a tough yeah it's definitely a
tough one to do but i think andrew you
knocked it out so congrats on your top
100
cannot wait for the all renders or not
the all renders well the old range will
be great but top 100 montage is going to
be insane
cannot wait
david
very handmade play claymation vibes yup
you can see the fingerprints in there
so good so cool the torches too are just
solid man
the clay chunks off the water right it's
like just such a very clay nation
specific right the little balls that
come off the water
that's so cool
amazing
i love the color here too
this is like warm but still cool
i want to be here the waterfall's so
cool too yes
yeah it has like a cellophane almost
look but yeah
yeah
good stuff david and textures
amazing
what this guy does before bed every
night
oh
the lull the lightning what oh what an
atmosphere on this one
yeah this one also feels like cold and
damp pretty wet render over look up this
one's a pretty wet render yes yeah look
at the like reflection off of the
clothes
so good
oof
i like out of
i'm not gonna say all the environments
but out of most of the environments
in the top 100 this one feels like
the most tangible like i can be in those
little huts if i wanted to the problem
is if i was in those huts i'd still be
damp like that's the feeling i get from
this
great caustics on the water by the way
back left really deep there you see
getting some caustics do you see that on
the uh on the reeds way way back in the
left underneath the buildings
underneath the
oh for real
left side of frame
right at the water line
oh is that mist or is that caustic it's
hard to tell
it could be mel no it's probably missed
it's probably missed a rolling mist
maybe
yeah
very well in china which is where you
see these kinds of uh tall
tower like rock formations
oh dude i've always wanted to visit that
place so cool it's pretty it's pretty
rad although i will say
you see it and then you're like okay
cool yeah oh this goes on for hundreds
of miles it's fine
oh man
yeah this is by
shang
shang hao lou shanghai lu
once again the phonetic spelling you're
freddy you're right
probably could help me for the finale
i'm just saying could help you out good
job
amazing render one of my favorites
cool very cool
congrats top 100
g
norman
oh
this render is base drop city
oh man this render starts not as wet as
the previous one
but
it gets there like is it get close
it's getting there it's getting there
with the
you know what this actually gives me a
lot of vibes for is this gives me like
almost
like
theme park ride vibes right almost very
theatrical the lighting you know
it it has this sort of energy of like
a theatrical sort of display with the
smoke instead of water right absolutely
yeah absolutely the the lighting that
like lightning flashes
actually terrify me because i'm like
whatever's making those light flashes
must be huge and the fact that they're
under oh yeah
like the fact that they're underwater
too is like what on earth is making
that light it's like dust yeah it's like
dust under water there oh i see i see i
see terrifying
see that isn't isn't it the hardest i
remember hearing somewhere that one of
the hardest things i think was like the
luca behind the scenes they were talking
about making something look wet
underwater oh is one of the hardest
things to do
it's like how do you communicate because
all of our visual indicators of what
wetness is
is it right is because it's on the
surface it's reflections it's the way
you know certain different materials are
when they're wet compared to when
they're dry you have so many visual
markers but when you're underwater you
have none of those visual markers that
were useless it's very hard to
communicate
wetness underwater right
yeah i feel like like what i don't i
don't know what they would do to do that
here because like i know it's under
water
but i don't like i think it's just
because it's a ship and like an octopus
thing
but other than that like
literally the first thing that comes to
mind is
the way
if you ever see like you have to the
only way to do it is you have to just
stare at stock footage stare at
reference images right i think that the
way that like dust moves when a big
heavy thing called falls into it right
it's slower but it also it's just it's
going through a thicker medium as well
yeah so it's hard it's very very
difficult very cool good point
solid stuff g norman g norman lippert
norman great put you in a nice spot in
the in the uh in the music too
definitely fitting for your writing yeah
it's very it's a very moody moody shot
yeah
uh this next one
oh this next one
whoa
this is by mitch mitch another og on the
server
whoa
dude this one is so cool
the reveal and like just the environment
i'm like who are these people
what is this like tribe
definitely a story
that you're getting through here mm-hmm
oh this is cthulhu ass
monster octopus in the background what
are you guys doing turn the boat around
they're going in they're going to stop
it
no i think that's where they chill dude
oh maybe they are fighting it it's a
good point
like they're going like look at the
guy's face on the left he's like he's
getting ready for something
you know
yeah yeah yeah yeah
this one is so cool this is like
preparing for war that's what i feel
like
they didn't bring enough ships
straight up dude yeah gotta bring more
ships i love the fog yeah the fog and
like the reveal to that there's
so much going on reveal the reveal
there's so much going on here yeah the
reveal
mitch mitch congratulations great design
uh great vibe man
great animation also not afraid to like
let you right we're putting the camera
on the boat so it's letting a tilt in
the horizon show up because that's what
you expect right yeah absolutely it's
subtle enough that it doesn't break the
montage because like they still need to
flow together um but you're you're
getting that sense of movement there and
it's perfect it's just perfect
congrats man
good stuff
oh boy this next one
crazy i i don't this is another one of
those ones that i think it's a very
specific uh render engine that gets you
this kind of look it might be arnold i
don't know um
but because i've never used it but
it's just it looks so real the way the
light
works with this one is just crazy
and the design like
the planet the planet's changing in the
background too very cool
oh and then as it gets darker you're
getting these silhouettes of these you
know these people like in the
worshipping poses i've done a lot of tai
chi i've never had a portal opened up
when i've done tai chi though
i must be doing i must be doing it wrong
definitely doing it wrong dude
yeah shoot
go back take some more classes
oh man
yeah this one uh who's it though yeah
dimitri you you're killing it with this
your lighting your color
the simulation and the cloth your 2d
elements that you brought in and like
tracked to his back just looks so good
particles yeah that's a yeah that's a
great evolution right it's like
ah yeah that's just a that's a great
that a little bit of depth in the portal
too like the little runes that's like
not even it's a flat image that's cool
yeah amazing
really good stuff dimitri congrats to
you
oh
my gosh
dude just clowning on everyone they
killed mm-hmm oh creepy taking their
souls it's the mask man
man if i get killed they'll take my soul
that's rough
that's rough that's the worst
oh the snake the serpent that comes up
at the end ooh you catch him for a
little bit
terrifying
absolutely terrifying beautifully lit
you got that moonlight vibe going really
nice the flames
in the back really help
build out the vibe i don't think it'd be
the same without those flames bad spooky
bad spooky
really nice volumetric fog on the left
and right too like
beautiful absolutely beautiful yash
all i'm saying is that she probably
planted those swords after she killed
them you know what i'm saying that's i'd
say that's a hard move to get five times
in a row
agreed unless like she's some
telekinetic powers but you know oh man
teleconnect powers that's so op it's
cheating at that point it's chilling
it's cheating
good stuff josh congratulations
uh freddie if you ever need to
use a little uh water break or something
you let me know and okay no problem yeah
just let me know
vlad
oh
the movement implications
oh it's like a giant
creation oh yeah it's like a big machine
yeah
yeah this rules cause like look at the
look at the people who have died and are
frozen in place trying to get through
this gate they didn't even know they had
to take tai chi lessons oh my god the
mechanism
right the application of like people
clamoring at the gates and this guy was
just like idiots this guy do you got tai
chi the key dude
that's so cool i actually never realized
that those people were there
yeah look at that oh wow that's amazing
this is actually how they opened up
black friday um
this universe
you know i mean this is the best buy
this is the best buy in the universe
everyone there's clamoring for them
deals dude it's thanksgiving they're
done and they want some
the ritual deals chi master to run the
lock though otherwise and i love that
the the movement there's such a force of
movement you're peeling some moss off
yeah it's just blasting it
and a great color scheme right little
mix of warm and cool
green green orange sort of like very
organic and also again not afraid to go
very strong on the background highlights
you know like sunlight the dappled
sunlight like you're willing to get
almost white with the column the first
column on the left you know yeah i dig
that don't be afraid of light don't be
afraid of that sun the sun's bright the
sun's super bright i love you know this
clint i looked at the sun for three
hours the other day oh so bright
yeah
don't do that goodness gracious dude
brutal watch those eyeballs dude
yeah just just you know just know the
sun's bright
glad
good stuff
good stuff got the bright sun you got
the people clearing it clamoring at the
gates
love your render congrats on your top
100.
very unique this one is one of the most
unique
looping here
it should be oh no particles oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah
black and white with a red kind of kind
of a little bit of the um a little bit
of vibes from the uh uh last thor movie
the black and white planet that they're
on right oh shoot never seen it but that
sounds cool
it is a little yeah it's good they got a
black and white planet dude are they
black they're they're not black and
white
ah they're kind of okay i'm kind of
zoned out of that one
i got you good movie good good work on
that movie though um very cool though
the basalt kind of towers locking into
place
kind of has a sci-fi with organic
feeling sort of elements yeah super cool
character too it feels super ancient and
very
dark
uh dark as in like i don't want to mess
with whatever's going on here yeah yeah
only a little bit wet
yeah yeah but pretty dry a pretty dry
comp
yeah they got they got a little bit of
water on the bottom and then like
there's some shine off the top of this
dude's dome
oh yes thank you so much
you got a bagel too
oh
i probably can't eat on stream
but save it thank you so much
yes
i love my wife she's the best
bagels and coffee let's go um anthony
congrats to you very good stuff
you got under
next
whoa
how wet is this one half wet
or full
this is a 50 wet yeah it's this part is
pretty wet but then this part's not wet
at all yeah so crispy
you know i'm really conflicted on this
one
this is a tough one dude yeah this is a
tough one
wow
i love like i just want to pause it on
the
so much background detail all right like
the graffiti and the
signage and the signage of different
stylistics oh wow
i love the reflection coming off the
ground there so good um one thing i see
you on the fog card look at the little
car that's coming through the fog
definitely watch out for that next time
um
dang eagle eyes dude yeah you know you
watch these runners enough you catch
everything
and i've done tai chi i need to go back
to do tai chi like look at this change
the weather hey that's a good thing if
this if this compilation gets people
doing tai chi that's that's a win
under solid very good stuff under
beautiful scene lots of attention to
detail
beautiful lighting great color
knocking it out man
cool very cool yeah
this has like kind of new york toronto
chinatown vibes that way it did yeah it
did
oh
look
little little breath of the wild water
kind of
i love the cel-shaded little cel-shaded
mix
super solid vibe i love these stylized
ones they stand out a lot to me because
again so many of these are
going for that realistic photo real vibe
but when you stylize it it's very very
very fun
stylizing i to me i think stylizing can
be it's a different obviously it's a
different set of difficulties but like
the difficulties come in you need to
make right photorealistic is just like
cool make it realistic i know what
realistic looks like but when it's
stylized you need to you need to be
coming up with what's the texture what's
the color schema
right like what's the palette that
you're drawing from what's the shape of
things these are all now decisions that
you as an artist need to be bringing to
the table
yep the design language has to like
follow because
exactly and they're doing a really good
job here like they're i love how these
guys are powering this dude with these
little coal blocks
very ghibly for sure yeah
so good
the little guy balancing the 2x4
[Laughter]
it's so funny he could he could just put
it down no no i don't think so right
because if it's a little long it's not
gonna he needs to be there oh you're
right okay you're right
i see you i mean i mean like he's
definitely got the short end of the
stick as far as like little robot guys
he gets the most gains though for sure
oh my gosh the never skipping leg day on
this nope
a little button press
good job yeah good job you're in
you're insane
super solid
we got another ennis
whoa
that effect
yeah that feels crisp bam that's one of
the that's one of the best environmental
um effects that i've seen on the top 100
here you wanna you wanna know why for me
because a lot of these things you do
grass little light things but there's a
mix of weights here that rock
the rock on the left
right that's snow shooting is what
cements
the impact because we understand things
that are heavy right we get that when
things are light don't go you know
but like when that heavy thing goes and
stops quickly too
shakes the trees too
yeah and like the smaller branches move
more than the bigger branches like it's
really well done solid impact and also
the lighting too just like the the the
orange red reddish light that kind of
has oh how cool yeah tummies doesn't
remind you of uh
the beginning
of eldon
a little bit it does it does
yeah a little bit of that going on this
is a pretty dry cop yeah though yeah
this is like give me some water this
isn't a salad this is not as much
it's not much allergy inducing but this
is a good dry cop agreed yeah couldn't
agree more ennis congratulations
love that
that effect is amazing
oh edge
robert
whoa whoa
yeah
[Laughter]
took took it upon himself to build not
one but two environments for this
challenge
i love that the that that the the vine
knocks down that bottle
yeah
as it comes in
okay if i if you could um
i know i know the answer all right i got
the answer
because because he told also another 50
what yeah yeah fair
very fair
yeah
um what is
the emotional like subtext
of the of this of this render what's
their story
this one feels like such to me what is
what i get from this is it's such a
breath of air right it's tight it's
constrained you feel the walls closing
in and then when it blows open it
literally and then with the combination
of that with the thing coming out the
flower blooming so it feels like just
taking a deep inhalation right there in
that moment right but like this is them
you know i'm saying this is the future
what's interesting about this to me is
this reads as like
like i don't know like the story that
this one tells is like it's like it's
you're close the mind right the mind of
this of this thing of this of this being
right it's like imprisonment and it's
garbage but it's like it's in the head
anyway yeah no that's easy that's
literally it you got it really yeah my
trap by your mind breaking out breaking
out yeah
yeah that's a crap if you can nail that
if that you can communicate that that i
got that from this abstraction means
that you've accomplished something
that's extraordinarily difficult which
is to com is to transpose concepts using
just imagery into someone else's mind
like that's why i love filmmaking right
like that's the hardest thing wow this
dude's young too
boy look out look out yeah
cool
tim
i see you tim
oh spooky we got a skeleton everyone was
in the beaver the whole time
[Laughter]
i love it
yeah some dark voodoo going on
you gotta be careful with that stuff
oh my gosh yes this is gonna be yo this
gives me some warhammer vibes oh and
it's been oh my god
yeah i love the lighting the top soft
top lit light super evil super dark the
wings too
yeah
yeah this one's sick
tim skeleton just ruining my day dude
amazing i know right no good definitely
no good giant like uh bones in the
background right at the top there
oh my god big old rib cage showing up
yeah
good this guy died and couldn't see this
yeah
you don't want to be in the dark world
that is for sure i'll be in dark world
zero on the wetness though right
pretty dry pretty dry zero on the
wetness there is blood there's a puddle
of blood
oh we gained a little bit five percent
at the very end
good stuff good stuff
christian oh
wait is this a bunch of little guys not
standing on top of each other
i that is like one of my favorite gags
and they'll get me every time
guys like little there's a bunch of
little rounds there's a bunch of them
could pick a tall one because they're
standing on each other a bunch of kids
in a trench coat it's so good yeah
a couple of a couple of these creatures
paid for the box seats and the swings oh
yeah they got this the freaking choice
seats
yeah this one is amazing i love it so
much it feels super unique
beautiful design beautiful world
beautiful simulations got butterflies
like i need more butterflies in my
render man oh cool
yup you know what's interesting about
this again it's very small detail but by
making this okay so it kind of has a
stage right by by looking making that
backdrop shorter than your subject yeah
you're you're emphasizing how tall the
subject is right oh okay because if
those if that backdrop was all the way
up top they'd be like yeah they
accommodated they knew how tall this was
but it's almost like says it says like
these little creatures designed the
stage but like normally right normally
they don't go above the stage so it
really says something to make it just a
bit shorter right
that's awesome that's such a small
little thing
that's but you're so right that's that's
the most important stuff the small stuff
has disproportionate effect on the
feeling of these things like the choice
is there the details
in those worlds
i love this one so
so much
yeah good stuff
christian you killed it four of them it
takes four of them to make that creature
yeah
there's like strings up on the shoulders
that like bend the legs and stuff and oh
well there's there's little like little
helper guys down there too oh helper
guys yeah the best the best
very cool
uh oh
robots mark the world
it's chill though but it's chill though
yeah
yo
super sick
oh wow that's like the fire team that
given cpr
still needing to give cpr but like
oh wow and all the
this is wow
so much going on uh you know so much
going on someone else who built out two
very detailed environments for the
challenge taking on a lot of work uh
this month but boy they nailed it that's
such a cool little teleport and their
final little world
totally looks like
they built it in mid journey and then
like reconstructed it in 3d
i wonder it's just such a cool but like
it's such a cool like the halls man it's
like
it's very yeah i feel like i haven't
seen that it's like it feels like this
amalgamation wouldn't get this light and
sort of buddhist structural thing going
but yeah cool oh my gosh so cool yeah
beautiful
the fog blind mission fog everything
killing it good stuff martin
we got a little taste test
rudy oh we got two taste tests
oh we got abraham lincoln vampire hunter
abram lincoln whoa yeah
super cool use of the mocap
oh cool yeah
oh yeah that that axe throw towards
camera is really what makes this one
yeah very unique very very unique doing
a great job focus and the focus pull
who is that david bowie like who i don't
know who that is
just a vampire dude is it gentleman's
booth
okay okay dude it's vamp john wilkes
booth as a vampire
lincoln's back and he's here to avenge
he's like you owe me a play
[Laughter]
so stupid oh it's hilarious
yeah this is good stuff rudy i love it
very creative good use good composition
good lighting knocking it out man good
impact on that axe yeah subtle camera
shake
good stuff
very good stuff
alex
boom
blow it out the back i think that may
have happened to me once or twice in
class before
you know you punch too hard you don't
kick too hard and just yeah do a punch
too hard dude blow out
oh that's really fun i love the scale
and proportion of this character
they look like um
someone that would be in like
some ad or something
like back to the postmates vibe of like
this has a very yeah but it's a very
underdog vibe something about making the
the neck and the head tiny like you
could just ring it like anyone could
grab this dude's neck and kill him so
like he's at a disadvantage
it's like even to the point like this is
like literally really weird and again i
think this is like i love the the
ripples on this the drop ceiling but
like
this character reads as an underdog to
me so i'm like that black belt for real
though you know what i'm saying is that
is that black belt is that green belt is
it the yellow belt yeah okay
if you use the question it's like what
are those what are the other belts here
what would make more sense
i think i just don't buy that this
person's a black belt unless this dojo
sucks you know what i'm saying
this does feel like i but then but then
the other end of things but when i look
at it like it looks like a dance studio
turned into a dojo a little bit so maybe
it does you know it's those those plie
bars those don't show up in a in a dojo
you don't need those that's fair
that is fair you ha we have other things
we have torture devices that you have to
sit in and crank and like do the splits
and you have to sit in them for like 30
minutes
alex i love it this is another one of
those where i think the lighting is uh
this is
like is this an arnold render i don't
know uh it's a deep one
but the lighting just feels
really good and it gives me that feeling
anyway moving on
you remember this game right did you
play this game
oh yeah yeah yeah you play sifu
i did i did i was terrible at it oh man
it was a hard game
yeah this is awesome they do a really
good job of
matching the uh the style of the game
perfectly and it's a perfect story
because you know as
the character dies they get older and
obviously you show that by the tree i
think and then
yeah the tree
cool
really good light change little time of
day change built into it
yeah looks like they crisped up the
animations a little bit did they i know
crispy a little crispier that was open
they could um fix any clipping issues
that there may have been um
but this animation like some you know
some turned out really nice some had a
little bit more flaws than the others
but this was one of the favorites this
is one of my personal favorites
yeah just very crisp yeah
yeah very very good stuff
congratulations
next up we got this one here
this one's sick
[Music]
yup
same animation
very different approach
but it's affecting the environment oh
yeah oh it's affecting the universe
she's like phil throw that plant over
there
dude if you were on that planet oh it'd
be over dude
if this happened on earth
i would just go straight into this wall
and i would just get flat like a pancake
you need to eat that's what you should
do yeah
i want to see the render that's the the
guy sitting and sitting in on saturn
just chilling and then all of a sudden
it'd be like uh like the inception
hallway scene you just get thrown to the
side and like hit the roof and but times
ten
love how it's also just there's a
there's a rainbow right there's a color
to it and right there right it's not
it's not just monochromatic it's not
just you know highlight so it's
beautiful the way they animated this
it's so subtle and it's very
minimalistic but it's super effective
yeah
this one also is in a very
particular point in uh the montage to
line up with the music so i can't wait
it's like the
the it's the animation side of it with
the 2d elements that
feel like to the elements that really
kind of like emphasize the motion right
that's like it's almost in this case it
almost feels like the the crispness of
the mocap is what's the you know what's
being built upon in terms of all the
elements
serving to emphasize that yep
100
yeah they did a great job affecting the
environment via the mocap and we're
gonna see
oh boy one of my favorite ones
um
here we go
oh man bad day at work
a bad day at work dude so good don't
point the gun at the alien what are you
doing
not a good move dude not a good move i
think this is andres
love the warping too the warping that
happens here like the environment
it's it's freaking perfect it bends it
warps the environment
sends the characters like into the wall
so hard dude his head
his head gets
ready
[Laughter]
okay so look look at the
woman oh just oh no
oh no deceased straight rag doll dude
and then the guy
that's really quick to be fair that's
what i look like when i go to sleep
that's in bed that's it that is
basically
i was gonna say i wake up like that
sometimes that's how i wake up i've seen
clint wake up like that yeah
yeah this is oh beautiful they're um
they're like
dust particulate is perfect their
lighting is perfect they're changing
the lighting multiple times through the
shot oh dude
well yeah it's like the blue and the red
coming in and stuff out very cool
yeah yeah don't point your don't don't
work at a place that requires you to
have a gun and pointed at an alien you
know
not smart
what do you think this was this is you
knew this was gonna happen when they
interviewed you not smart
um freddie we are at a halfway point i
might just use the restroom real quick
okay take a little water break so we can
i'll throw it to the brb screen i'll be
back in two minutes uh does that sound
good to you freddy yeah that sounds good
to me i'm gonna get a little little bevo
as well sweet all right y'all halfway
through see you into everyone's enjoying
this yeah to see some more wet renders
some damp wet renders coming up in the
second half folks everyone take a little
take a little water break get some water
in you take a respite see y'all soon see
you soon
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
how you doing freddie i can't wait i'm
it's doing good dude yeah
seeing these renders really feeling like
i should have gotten more into 3d you
know
oh dude it's all good it's all good
you're doing big things very big things
um
and this 3d is a big part of of telling
stories and and knowing how to do so is
very very helpful so
um
you know it's never it's never too late
absolutely never too late no that's true
that's true i started getting into
blender a little bit because i've been
doing more clay stuff and i've been
modeling like sculptural elements in
blender it's really it's fun it's good
yeah absolutely absolutely
um
yeah i was gonna say like you're doing a
lot of
a lot of uh sculpting now and i was
wondering if you're right now with my
hands yeah using uh mid journey to
create some stuff
i have i have some more yeah i've been
messing around with like ai forms and
ceramics and interestingly my conclusion
at this point is actually
that these the ai forms are actually uh
garbage
really
yeah i actually look at them now and i
think there's actually
it's not that there's nothing there
i think that they're great practice
but also i think i like i feel like yeah
i don't know i'm in a very conflicted
place with where what ai is able to do
especially in the form of ceramics which
is the 3d three-dimensional art form and
very much in the meat space world it's
been it's been interesting exploring it
and i have a couple of facebook world
what that says that's us right here baby
that's meat space what is meat space
meat space is real life
that's what that means
yeah meat space
never ever like cyberspace is like the
internet and stuff and it's like what's
the opposite of cyber space what's meat
space it's us flesh i see i see i see
never heard that one before interesting
um
yeah okay so yeah ai art is uh that's a
whole other thing i don't even want to
get into it now because that will be the
rest of this that'll be the right whole
lives yeah honestly
yeah honestly uh let's hop back into the
art we're happy let's get back in there
let's jump in
all right this was uh andrus andre's x
amazing amazing amazing art but freddie
buckle up dude okay
[Laughter]
and the reactions yeah look at him
standing up and clapping like amazing oh
and the video reactions no way
this is one of my favorite uses of the
data here of the mocap
data this is
ace
just
ace
like the fact that the character like if
you were doing this if you were on this
game show by the way this is a real
japanese game show i don't know the name
of it but
uh
so basically you have to fit the shape
of this wall coming at you um there's an
oh my god freddie there's another good
one where a scooter you have to like
ride a scooter down a hallway that gets
narrow and narrower it's so good um
but if you were on the show like you
would
probably try and find the pose you would
post up and be like is this it is this
it
no this character goes for it chad this
giga chad just show it
this one's the best this one has like
some of the best emotion in it for me
it's incredible also you know what
really really subtle
like observation right the camera is in
the same plane as that are right like
you can make you can make this weird if
the camera is not in the right spot but
the camera has a hole to go through so
it's like they
shoot arm is on the same
planer right that's cloud i didn't
notice that but of course
oh it's so funny
the pool like the little pool behind
them this gets white points
let's get some wet points yeah
so good
simone simon i love it this is the best
make me so happy hilarious hilarious
this next one is by light
whoa
goodness
yeah like deus ex vibes
specific rim vibes definitely specific
rim
i can't specific rim dude specific
wow
i can't not say that anymore um anyway
the environment 10 out of 10 like the
breath of the wild still being still
selling strong
selling strong dude look at that
that banner cost thousands
the little pot falling off immediately
at the top there cactus the cactus is
gone oh no
that hit someone
i hit someone
no the streets are cleared when the
robots are out
my only problem with this render is i
feel the robot is a little
dare i say robotic
but that's what a robot is clint i guess
you know they're just huge
subtle subtle thing here but a little
motion in the uh the water coming in
right it's not just like water coming
out you get a sense of like sometimes
you know like when it's windy and it
rains you'd see like the ripples yeah
in the puddle uh on the on the feet
good wet render just a good wet one it's
a good one
god
it's a good one pretty wet pretty um the
like little rain halo on the
on the balcony is great the way the
robot light kind of passes over the
foreground is amazing yeah yeah
definitely definitely becoming a
backlight becoming that back rim light
on them yeah
you also get you also feel it's not in
the shot but you feel the helicopter
flying overhead right there right
yeah look at the top you got highlights
from from a top spotlight on the robot
you feel like there's a helicopter up
there oh my god you're right i thought
you were being there i thought you were
joking 100 but you're 100 right i don't
joke about art
not not at all
it's not a laughing matter
it makes it feel huge
render
yeah the scale is great good stuff light
top 100
let's go
stefano
upgrade the house downgrade the house i
know i was like oh man i've been awesome
to just keep it like keep keep the the
smiles going but he's like no get real
kid
i'm interested in the bikes does the
bicycle get better yeah the bicycle
becomes brand new too you see that
mm-hmm got a little tag on it tassel
little tassel then it's back
this is kind of uh like 1.5
environments they made here yeah
yeah the mailbox turning into a lantern
it's like i don't need mail where i'm
going
i love them yeah i love those elements
that morph right the pottery turns from
the from the axe you know and the tree
yeah it's cool the lantern in the back
stays too it just turns into a little
paper lantern so good
yeah
really good stuff stefano nice color
get some particulate
oh the one thing you didn't need my
friend
was i don't know if you're seeing this
freddy but the uh the lens
smudges
not i don't think that was necessary
actually i'm looking at it yeah
not needed
you're doing a great job without it
um and technically they would be pretty
blurred out you wouldn't see them crispy
like that so keep that in mind
but congrats on top 100 stefano you're
getting that kit bash kit along with all
the other artists here
on the stream today moving on
to kenneth
oh i've been in a forest when this has
happened you don't want to be around
brutal dude
dude so spooky
look at these wait who was it that told
me about the pigs
what
oh it was jan
he said
he was on a shoot in like south america
or something and
he like
went out to one wheel late at night
and off the side of the road he shined
his headlamp
into the forest
and he saw like 20 eyes reflecting back
at him
and he said nope
well you're getting the eye reflections
here too right you see the little wolf
oh yeah 100
yeah 100
and there's some demonic stuff going on
yup pretty dry pretty pretty toasty
pretty dry but uh very i
that foreground pass of the wolf is fun
agreed yeah it gives you that feeling of
once again of depth and of sort of an
evolving story that's happening agreed
yeah it brings it all together i love
those like dangly
little like artifacts in the trees
there's
see a handful of them and one comes in
here to be they appear to be essentially
upside down almost like russian orthodox
cross is made of bones terrifying
oh i'm just saying i see if i see one of
those in the forest i'm turning around
you know i mean i'm going back to my car
oh
really really nice use of the mocap data
here
turning character into particles dig the
fire dig the lighting just dig the whole
thing kenneth
congratulations to you
way to knock it out
steve
steve
the bongers oh there's a
whole row oh whoa
metatrox this is og on the server whoa
it's oh wow it's like it's
it's so cool to be able to see the
reflection
of the person right you're seeing the
back angle of the same mocap and then
having it be controlling some oh that's
so cool
yeah a lot went into this this is uh
unreal engine
um they got a nice like video feed of
the robot on the bottom
like center left there
yeah you're right super cool um
you know very specific rim
very much so
uh and good job you know they cheated
like the waves in the water too
and it totally sells yeah yeah yeah
balanced composition here almost a
triangle from the top going downwards
right displays out you get the various
robots positioned
yeah
yeah there's a lot going on
and you see how the chain is a hologram
when he pulls it
in the foreground oh heck yeah
definitely
oh cool
very cool
yeah that's awesome you did a really
good job uh this is metatrox steve
um
you did a great job like
balancing so many different elements
in the shot is a lot but you can you can
clearly tell what's going on so congrats
to you metatrox for making top 100 baby
let's get it
to roll
is next this one's pretty interesting
pretty interesting story on this one
yeah it's like a similarly right like
controlling the thing
summoning this giant beast rock beast
he's had it with this with the
punishment
it's brutal
yeah yeah almost like almost has very
strong like what is it like eldon ring
church vibes 100
yep like i'm there's a bonfire you got
saved dude we gotta save real quick it's
close by too i can i can see it probably
in the background somewhere there this
is nice i like your moonlit scene you
got a nice nice cloth sim going um
pretty pretty nice story you have going
to
um
yeah there's like justification for the
character doing their action
interesting yeah yeah hats off to you
good stuff to all
moving on to
shay ah gross dude
man this got really creepy over
uh
very unsettling it's the center of like
oh go ahead yeah purple orange right
yep agreed very spooky uh this one also
feels like that kind of uh
like amusement park lighting
kind of situation like a ride
some indiana jones maybe
yeah yeah i love the implication of way
in the back right you have this like low
underglow light
and it shows up and then slowly it
disappears in in stages as it backs off
from it
yeah she knocks the candles out too with
that hit it's pretty solid
dang this is like evil tai chi dude
definitely some evil type can you take
classes can you take classes on evil tai
chi is there any could you imagine going
into a tai chi placing me like do you
guys teach
evil tai chi before like a forbidden tai
chi
it's like get
dude i think i looked at you with like a
really serious eyes and just like get
out i'd be like this place does teach
evil tai chi i just gotta like maybe pay
a little bit more
god could you imagine doing evil tai chi
learning evil tai chi and then leaving a
bad yelp review you can't if they're
teaching you evil tai chi and they can
do this sort of stuff you can't leave a
bad yelp review that's just asking for
it
yeah yeah i wouldn't mess with gotta
give it like five stars five stars great
because you get the ants sick on you
like like they got all the pots in the
background you know like yeah ants
crawling out of stuff dude it's not good
it's not a good life yeah yeah
good stuff shay
love it
oh man i love this one so much
lexinsky vibes what's that
uh vexinsky is a is a painter who gives
these paints these very surreal dark
creepy environments that are very
reminiscent of the background of this
one okay i because i'm all about this
background um it feels very unique to me
i love the lighting it just
feels polluted and
you know it feels like uh
what i would imagine the ending of the
stalker book
to
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
this is this is great picnic
this is jay lee
you're killing it here with your
lighting
uh this is another one where i think
it's that same render engine it has that
look to it um
absolutely beautiful i'm very curious to
see how you built out those like web
structures in the background here
so freaking cool they feel like they
might even be just 2d elements
they could be definitely the backpack
ones definitely could be yeah yeah
a little brain
do i detect a little bit of fiddling you
do you do yeah it looks so good and like
very very very vexinsky vibes on this
one i like it
congrats jalee i love it you're also in
a really nice spot in the render or in
the montage with the music
so
look forward to it
uh one week from now top 100 montage
goes live yeah it's been
what wait was that the beginning of us
oh they're saying
yeah they're saying maybe a little bit
louder maybe i'm pretty loud i'm coming
in hot
am i on my end
maybe sodo i don't know double check the
levels maybe uh oh he's got at least oh
bro he had a laser sword this whole time
dude the whole time i love this
he pops it into his uh
yeah i'm getting some power rangers mega
man
vibes here a little dead space little
dead space right i can see it with the
character yeah
at least the helmet at least the helmet
totally oh it took out the electricity
for the whole block when he powered up
his laser sword i know it dissipated all
that pollution dude
but like at what cost you know it's like
he's got to fight the crime
yeah that's true that's true that laser
sword's
old white
definitely yeah really nice cool way to
mix it up very monochromatic until that
sword shows up right like very mod for
magnet that is just like a splash of
this counter color yeah it's hard
very good stuff
this is luis
congrats luis loving it loving your
stuff man
who is next oh this one's solid
oh
ahmed
wow
is this a destination thing or is this
like custom
this it's got vague destiny you'll have
like these giant
um you don't have this giant praying
mantis and destiny a little bit of
destiny vibes
um feels like a hunter but like they're
like cooler character design than like
what destiny's got gives you though
sweet yeah i love the uh the lighting
here and the atmosphere is
super solid it's really tough
effect yeah mm-hmm
yeah the magic effect is really nice
kind of gonna be like yeah yeah yeah
cool what does it remind you of oh the
elven ring dude
the best yeah
cool
sparse landscape very cool very cool
yeah that's stranding vibes actually too
yes i could definitely see that uh the
desolate foggy atmospheric background i
i was gonna say that like
it's tough to do an alien planet alien
world and
have it feel good um yeah yeah i think
they're doing a really solid job here
yeah good stuff
any final thoughts freddie or should we
move on let's move on this is great
though i like this one
not wet unfortunately not at all pretty
dry
yeah
renault this one's wet here we go this
one's wet this one look at that lily pad
that's a wet lily pad that's a good one
man
beautiful
cool yeah i love the colors it's simple
this is like flies might be going
extinct what fireflies might be going
what do you mean might be like
like
will be if we don't do something or
might be like who knows maybe
do the habitat loss pesticides like
there's less fireflies now than there
were and you know
yikes
yikes is right
well at least they live on in the
renders
we're gonna preserve these fireflies and
the renders
i love that um
that renault you did a really good job
of
taking a very bite-sized small scene
here and spending your time on that you
didn't bite off
too much you're doing something that's
very doable and and uh you're not
getting ahead of yourself so i think
you're doing a solid job here yeah it's
all all the pieces come together really
well there's a very distinct and clean
arc uh artistic sort of imprint on this
which i like
yeah very good stuff
[Music]
adarsh
oh you know what this is it might be
because i'm seeing an obs my my thing is
like down a little bit can you just
crank that all the way up for a guest
camera
whoa
test test test test test yeah check i
should be at the same level as clint now
but
whoa
a lot of detail this yeah this one
is one of the more
beautiful environments in the top 100
it's uh
the volumetric lighting here going
scattering through the trees
and dappling
yeah
through the cloth too and different
parts of it
yeah good subsurface scattering
uh your your environment
looks extremely photo real i know this
is blender
um
people you know there's a lot of
stupid back and forth on what program is
better
than what and it's all about what you
make in the program it's not about the
program itself so anything can be done
in any program
but yeah it's just whatever fits you as
the artist
absolutely yeah absolutely
unless you're working in like production
environments and everyone's got to use
the same thing but like you know you're
just doing your own thing do your own
thing
everyone's got a black belt i've yet to
see a non-black belt in terms of
so true dude
i want to see next time i want to see
some people with like bad you know what
i'm saying worse belts
yellow belts where's the where's the
purple belts at
i'm saying where my purple belt actually
purple i think was purple is kind of
high in uh it is high yeah green and
yeah i don't know yellows yellows and
oranges you know
yeah okay
tim
oh
those are great rocks
beautiful lighting beautiful color
uh these the sort of flowing sort of
like light particulate things in the
background in the foreground here kind
of give it nice depth mm-hmm
yeah it actually nice depth and cohesion
agreed it ties it together ties the
foreground in the background together
but i think what would have been cool
this is very very subjective but you
could actually reverse the direction of
the foreground particles so it feels
more like a circle ah so it does like
that oh that's interesting yeah yeah so
it's like the background's coming in and
then playing out in front of you oh you
know what oh yeah
i like how bold the lighting right like
the the lighting on the uh back rocks
there almost to a you know
pushing to such a bright highlight which
helps you know silhouette the character
but also again bold choice sun's bright
it's okay that the sun's bright right
ready how many hours do you look at the
sun yesterday
i looked at it for about three hours i
got this big black spot right in the
middle right here so i'm just launching
everything through the corner of one of
my eyes what what did you determine
though like how i determined that the
sun was really bright sunspring so if
you're checking don't worry at least for
now i checked it yesterday still bright
still freaking bright as we can see in
this render great job um
and look at the freaking volumetric
lighting on the left it's beautiful nice
waterfall
killing it
killing it good stuff tim congrats top
100 baby
jordan
is next
[Laughter]
the guys recording it on their phone
yeah
oh and the tidy one this is see now
this is really funny
this is right there's the implication
here i'm just like all right what's
going on right the light's green
everyone's stopping this guy's
managed to keep the safety vest on but
everything else right and also the where
the traffic break is you know that this
is just happening oh wow
yeah pretty sweet pretty sweet at first
you're like
why is he in his underwear
that feels random but then you see the
guy with the phone and you're like
okay
he knows yeah he knows something's going
on jordan knows
yeah this is uh this is this is great
i love that cartoon style cracked me up
the moment the moment it started to
crack me
good stuff jordan
amazing work very good
oh this one's so good
victor
whoa
it was like those little sparkly uh
fireworks
totally
the kinds of fireworks that you're
disappointed by but not in a 3d sense
just in real life you know you've got
such louder other fireworks agreed just
a little the little push
from the uh the biplane right there
right there like yeah a sense of
something sucking in
nice effect on the environment it's that
it's it's you can really tell the
difference when
you know artists take time to
integrate the actual mocap data into the
environment what effect is it having on
the environment and it really just makes
it you know larger than life and
justifies the fact that we're in 3d we
can do anything we want so why not go
beyond real life you know and and so
many of these renders do that
this one included
amazing work victor your lighting is
solid
your design in this room is super solid
good animation too
yeah
heck yeah
who's next
remy oh
kind of similar
cool
yeah
some good puppet renders
those are like the little um
like the little drawing models the pose
models
yeah they're very popular with these
challenges a lot of people doing the
well it's because you got nice joint
articulation
it's simple
i see particulate in the air
tells me that this is a dry render
okay yes yes you know wet renders don't
have little uh little little dust dust
aliens
just
aliens
they're just that's what everyone thinks
aliens are dust they are like dust every
time you see a video and it's like oh my
gosh look at that thing moving like wow
you found a bird or dust
that's so stupid
ugh
i saw a video on instagram just zooming
in on this thing as rock on mars and
it's like aliens
i'm like what are you guys talking about
oh this is great yeah um
i like the
the like little erasers the box of
erasers and stuff on the left is really
nice
yeah the to-do list
overall solid render remy
congratulations to ya
all right
who's next
oh god
my boy
yeah
yeah
look at that
how considerate
so considerate dude
who's
what i want to find out what government
is launching missiles at totoro that is
a great question because this is not
okay
a great vlog what a fun render
i love the color the lighting is just
beautiful yeah it's very soft and
fluffy i didn't know
totoro had a belly button
what
do you see like totoro's got a little
dimple there on the belly button
and like
that's wild because that implies
umbilical birth from the totoros right
i guess you're right i never thought
about that you don't know i mean you
don't get belly is that candy that's not
cannon though that's not candy i'm
pretty sure this is this is a little
addition
in there just to make sure that hayao
miyazaki doesn't arouse from his slumber
it was the belly button that did it
there's the belly button yeah i love the
love that big old totoro teeth and
everything yeah fun little render yeah
great smile great render good quality
good lighting good color good everything
good composition good idea
ten out of ten super solid this is um
uh chinese characters i cannot that i
cannot read but sen sends
is what they put next to that so
if that is your name congratulations for
top 100
yi shang is next
you sean
oh
[Music]
again years of tai chi never done that
oh in the background too oh no
the guy in the background's standing up
he's like yo a formidable opponent
fighting are we fighting
your kung fu is not as good as mine his
uh his yin yang sign is burning
back there yeah
i think it's the first time i've seen
this sort of like construction of the
yin yang sign like from like kind of
angular from both sides coming around
it's kind of cool yeah
this this environment is insane the
lighting and the the atmosphere you're
doing a really good job of using those
clouds to separate the
layers in the mountains
yeah
yeah
good quality a little after trail little
after trail of the movement dude once
again something i feel like i can do but
turns out i can't
yeah beautiful render
ye
congratulations to you for making top
100 your render is also in a very very
nice spot with the music
so you look forward to that top 100
montage next week
dude i can't wait
oh this one's cool
oh just chilling
oh that little crisp movement into it
really cool
yeah the ground passes right at the
beginning
oh and the change to change like
the desk stuff you know the stuff the
tchotchkes on the desk to like oh yeah
now it's like um they had some bushes
very cool
it's very difficult
trying to build two environments for
this challenge but wow they knocked it
out
very cool that is for sure so detailed
yeah above and beyond for sure really
really really nice work
oh man all the like
destroyed posters and stuff like
on the left yeah a lot with the textures
the textures in the urban environment
are really really fun
just like the weird anachronistic like
chandelier right under the bridge it's
just just this interesting visual pop
oh greed
so good and then there's also a variety
of people right it's like it's a modern
era you got business guy you got tourist
guy with a backpack
it has a big mix of culture
it feels right
it definitely feels right cool little
market scene
let me hit that boom
beautiful
nice little forest
i want one of these where it's like the
guy in the background's like what like
he shows up in the new spot to like what
that's pretty funny
that's pretty good
yeah really really good stuff take this
render
just lush urban lush lush natural
oh
no
not good explosions
yet another yet another yeah another
bad day at work for three of them
this is uh sky
xpe on discord been winning a lot of the
weekly challenges you did a really solid
job uh getting ready for this big
challenge and i think those weeklies
helped you
they're a little bit of like uh like a
like a vhs filter feels like on it just
like a little bit of grain a little bit
of like uh
there's green but when it when that hit
goes there's definitely some chrome abs
coming in
yeah
there's something really interesting
about doing a sci-fi post-apocalyptic
kind of look using a vhs filter you know
yeah i guess that could be a really nice
way to like blend two different styles
that you wouldn't normally think to and
kind of get a unique look from it yeah
very borderlands feeling
yeah yeah yeah a little bit little what
was that id game was it rust or what was
the one not rust it was there was one
yeah
four letter of the fury or something
like that so close
oh boy i know exactly what you're
talking about it's like a hot sunlight
it was the one that like they were like
hell we didn't have to do any textures
it's all just one mega texture and
everyone's like cool the game though is
kind of boring
yeah it was like i just remember being
very very bright and very hot and uh
yeah high contrast and yeah you get that
here it looks nice
yeah very good
good stuff good stuff skye
nara is next with this like
friggin travelocity
like looking oh cool doing the oh cool
the 2d you see that yeah
oh that's cool
yeah this is like nintendo level looking
thing that's very clever right to take
to do to do like that just the clouds
and stuff as this 2d element is this
blend
that's cool it is awesome because the
sand looks photo real
and
yeah you know
of course like the facial expression on
the popsicle person
is definitely cartoony but you're mixing
these two styles really really well
i love the
like nintendo looking palm trees
yes yes very donkey kong country oh yeah
two you know what i mean uh-huh
exactly these people by the way i've
seen people in chat being like this is
so discouraging listen
you got to remember tell them there's
always people who are better than you it
doesn't matter how good you are there's
always people who are better than you so
what you got to do is you got to take
that you got to take that energy of like
no someone's better than me
yeah transform it transmogrify in your
mind because that's going to be a given
that's going to always be given no
matter what art form you do no matter
what you're doing is always someone
better than you so that should just you
should try and transmogrify that into
drive and to be like wow this is cool
i'm going to try something too use that
as a source of inspiration not as a
source of demotivation
that's a very very good point there's
also people who are worse than you too
there's always gonna be people better
there's always many people worse
and that's just gonna be it for the rest
of your life so there's not really any
point in like
you know
sticking with that if it's if it's more
of a negative thing like definitely try
and move past it what's what's important
is that you always should always be
pushing yourself always be pushing
yourself to do a little bit better or a
little bit different or try something
that you haven't done before you're lit
you got to always be just a little bit
outside of your comfort zone i think if
you're going to approach this if you're
going to learn from if you're going to
grow from anything if you're not if you
feel like oh i'm just going to do this
this this and i know exactly how to do
it you're not learning anything you're
just sort of putting together stuff you
already know how to do which is fine but
if you want to push yourself you should
always push yourself
agreed yeah cause you're gonna you just
plateau if you're never out of your
comfort zone
and when in doubt make it wet get it wet
i could have said it better myself
that was a that was a solid solid uh
little motivation to hit there though
very very true um
one last note that i want to mention
though is like
there will be people better than you and
if you can try and surround yourself
with those people because you're going
to learn from them yeah you get better
if you're if you're the best person on
the team and you're looking around
everyone's like you're just clowning on
everyone else you don't get better
they'll get better but you won't you
want to surround yourself with people
who are better than you
yep
very true very true
uh
pearson
oh
so nice that they gave him chairs
honestly
you know so many of these
post-apocalyptic scenarios these sci-fi
scenarios everyone's standing at
attention this one it's like you know
what human beings like to sit
and i actually appreciate that detail a
lot
this one's awesome it's it's very simple
um
a simple environment but i love their
character
that costume is so cool the balloon
necklace dude what the heck
yeah it feels like it's a shot from a
larger sci-fi story right there's a
story here right that that there's an
audience and they're all appearing to be
like soldiers it feels like you know
some of these like you know uso
performances in world war ii the camera
motion is being incorporated to show
there's a crowd watching right like
there's like a lot of story and world
building details in this
yeah really solid lighting and color as
well um
i get this feeling that it's like a
almost like blessing a it's like a
blessing before you go into battle or
something
before yeah i guess i get the sense of
like it's leisure right it's these
soldiers have come down to this planet
and they're almost like
like you know
what this is about yeah or something
like that like a little bit there's a
little bit because i just see from the
body language of the soldiers there's a
certain detachment there they're not
rigid at attention they're not leaning
forward in their seats they appear to be
just kind of like all right okay
interesting kind of detached which is
interesting yeah yeah it's good it's
just rained so it's like damp you know
there's um the character on the left
their leg they got like the jitters in
their leg it's a really nice detail oh
yeah you're right i didn't even notice
that
um
yeah i i dig this i dig this vibe so
much pearson you've been
uh
submitting to these challenges for the
last
three challenges i think so it's really
cool to see your progress and
kind of see how your renders look
similar there's a similar style to them
but they develop over time so
congratulations for making top 100
pearson very good stuff
[Music]
beautiful little market very detailed
environment awesome lighting
yeah by pushing it all to the left right
but you know you can you got that choice
of sun position but using that left and
then using that to highlight just like a
little box of flowers here just the
environment itself and then
and you're getting what little cat in
the deep background the people moving is
all the deep background but it feels
like this little little side alleyway
right where this is happening this
totally reminds me of a shot out of like
baraka or something oh yeah yeah
i just love the culture in here it feels
like there's this is a world that exists
and it has existed right a lived in
geometry and to me it's like when you
look at like the the the air conditioner
right and the it's like it just feels
like it's been it's been hacked on to
the buildings like these are old
buildings and it feels old
agreed it feels very ancient the stone
walls and everything
um
beautiful beautiful render
conal i think this is from canal
solid stuff congrats on top 100 there's
three cats
and a chicken in this water
there's two chickens two chickens and
three cats
where's the chicken chicken on the roof
i don't see the chicken and then um to
the left of the character's right leg
oh there's a cat sleeping in the sun too
oh wow yeah uh on the right side as well
no yeah super sick good stuff
very cool
robin
[Music]
oh spooky yeah
oh
interesting the just the barest hint
of this agent 47 meets cat uh uh um
captain cur captain picard kind of guy
in the background he's just in the
background this is just a hint of like a
little blush of light really adds to the
sort of mood of this yeah i think like
that and having like the not dead but
like lying down ones yeah it's very
moody
super creepy it's like
is this is this guy chill or not i don't
know i i'm not getting chill vibes from
this guy just gotta say you're not
getting like clowns like he seems like a
bad skin care regimen based on what i'm
seeing of the hand so that just tells me
right away god that's difficult right to
be able to kind of like write that that
because the hate wow i love how the hand
animation
is is integrated in with it right you
see how the fingers kind of bend and
move around oh that's i feel like that's
tough
that is tough now that you mention that
geez
like right are you reverse engineering
that based on the real movements is
there a way that you can write like wow
wow yeah cause they definitely took the
animation and they made it their own it
still fits right like there's you still
get like the the eighty percent moving
frags a little bit i wonder if the way
you do it is by doing it upside down
right and imagining that this is that
the character's pulling upwards on it or
the force of it right
yeah that's cool that's cool
dang it's really good
yeah yeah the finger the finger
animation some work
nice lighting too got the warm and the
cool
and the candles seem to react to the
movement
the uh
the movement the candles react and
flicker to the big movements
creepy
creepy
one the only note
you gotta get three different sims for
them candles
you can tell it's the same one copied
and pasted at least it looks so
interesting oh you're right yeah
but that's okay that's so nitpicky who
cares about that you can throw some you
can get a little wetter too
fair
fair i feel like it's dry stuff in the
air dry render
this animation is happening over
okay so this animation i'm just making
this up connecting these renders
together
is happening over this
in one of these little cabins back here
oh yeah right it's the same world yeah
it's like if you go in one of those
then this is kind of like what what
they're doing
ugh
yeah i'm really i'm really really into
the hand render though yeah
once you mention it you're totally right
it's so detailed
i'm creeped out i need another one let's
do it let's let's let's take a breath
here simon
low body fat
little vertical elevator movement love
it yeah it's cool
feel that rush right great little
tropical environment
yeah
good volumetric light in the forest
nice atmosphere to break up the little
sky islands
is this an avatar thing like that that's
like avatar made that the floating
islands thing definitely definitely
avatar i think was probably the big pop
culture influence i get always anytime i
see that kind of thing i always get like
mist and riven vibes
yeah yeah yeah
super cool nice little cabin on the
right too
very subtle
yeah
yeah
yeah good stuff simon
great lighting
really really good stuff
who's next
who is next
magic
oh whoa hold on what's going on here
what
[Music]
what
man this feels like
this feels like i'm watching
the wildest 80s cartoon you know what i
mean right totally yeah set in like
caleb yeah that red this is a red green
for me that's like
it's really tough to do
like a purplish oh and i love the low
frame rate on the background the animals
right like it kind of
yeah there's like a it feels like
there's a mix of frame rates at play
here and it ties together i think really
well agreed
yeah the like drawn in motion blur too
is super cool
let's see
yeah yeah yeah look at the look at the
mix of frame rates even just a little
bit oh cool
yeah the swords are going in the back
but then she's going every
two you're ever on a planet and swords
are falling out of the sky at that rate
don't be on that planet that's a good
that's a very very good note
i'm just gonna make a note of that if
nasa and nasa if we ever show up in one
of these plants and their swords falling
out like turn that ship around dude
slingshot back to earth go back home
good stuff magic i love it it's very
very unique it's one of the most unique
oh man that's so cool
made us
daniel
oh no
i know right i was like definitely eaten
whoa
that's so much fun yeah
i'm really good
go ahead yeah yeah look oh i'm just
saying i just i love the scale of it
when your first check wait oh he's small
and then when he comes by like it looks
like kind of like monkey king a little
bit right totally
my boy son will calm dude oh there's
some good monkey king stuff coming up
yeah the animation on the tiger is
really good
attacker got punched i know poor tiger
boom
oh
feels like i'm seeing i'm just seeing
like action lines off let's see real
quick yeah like a little burst of action
lines almost
anime lines boom
let's see if we can see if we can find
them these guys oh yeah
right there we'll sell a little impact
there love it
really good stuff
cool very cool yeah this one got me
we got farm
up next
super unique render
maybe one of the most unique what
[Applause]
oh clever
wow clever clever clever clever
the different color the reds and oh wow
yeah i want to chill in each one of
these little rooms they're so cool
wow what a fun little what fun
environment
it feels very
like commercial
those individuals yeah
yeah
this is like it feels like this feels
like this feels like the start of like a
music video right oh 100 percent each
one's each bad memories
like those shadows and the different
shadows interact with each other but
like right like oh that's so cool
totally playing around with like sort of
the shadow puppetry as a theme right you
know a lot of those environments remind
me of like sort of the intricate cutouts
you see in shadow puppets
heck yeah i love the depth too in the
in the rooms themselves like it's a very
flat renderer but the rooms push back
especially that top one is super cool
sweet good stuff very cool what's the
phone
emmitt
this one's freaking crazy this is like
uh
if you get out of the nebuchadnezzar
and it's just yeah dude you don't want
to get out of the nebuchadnezzar um and
you want to get out of the
nebuchadnezzar but there's still a pizza
place and the 7-eleven nearby you can
still get some grub yeah it makes you
feel like like you're at home for sure
but yikes oh there's a character off to
the left too doing something
chilling i guess on the balcony
oh yeah you're right yeah
i love i love the ones that also show
you another point of view from the same
animation right so seeing the sword in
the game
it's like it's so cool yeah i agreed
it's like little stuff like that that
gets me amped to make stuff
i want pizza so bad right now oh ready
we're getting i know i know
i'm going for pizza after this i'm just
saying
in time so many pizza vibes pizza vibes
pretty dry render but i love that you
know you get the sense of sunset
a green thing yeah agreed you get that
red light
good stuff even and evening's the best
time to play video games you know
agreed yeah agreed
or very early morning
when's the last time you woke up this is
such a random question when's the last
time you woke up and watched a movie
like first thing oh
long it's been a long time since i've
done that
you recommend it i i did it with uh with
bloodsport like last week
yeah and it was it was awesome like part
of me felt like i got to get to work but
the other part of me was like i am
working
yeah yeah yeah
love it
highly recommend it
emmett good stuff congrats on top 100
you get that kit bash kit all you all
getting kid bash kits
moving on to ricardo
i love this one
whoa
weird
very creepy dirty vibes yeah the
the like texture
imperfection work on the glass that
frosted glass makes it for me
yeah it has this very plastic bag feel
in there oh wow that's cool
it does appear to be just the ups select
um usps select shipping label okay yeah
just from uh
you're probably right yeah you're
probably right
um that's so funny but it is really but
it reads though as
wow
i love the like that
that the cloth sim that balloon looking
simulation above well it's not a
simulation but they had to
they had to simulate it to puff it up
that little like
almost insulation looking
real quick people are asking maybe some
new people to it what do i mean when i
say wet render or dry render it's
entirely based on if i feel like it's
wet or if it's dry that's it
so this one's like a light damp lightly
damp yeah it's insane just a little damp
agreed yeah i agree you couldn't get
those hand prints without it
yeah a little foggy you know a little
condensation in this one i dig this one
it's very simple but it's a great idea
good use of the mocap
yeah very cool
this one is a wet this one's wet
this one's a wet render
i love that character walking by on
their phone it's it's so small yeah it's
just like whatever i don't care it's the
mask yeah the mask yeah
i love the color of it the pink and the
orange right it's just such a cool and
oh just catching it off that wet ass car
as it goes by mm-hmm
pause on that car for me would you i got
you
oh oh yeah you love to see it look at
that oh good reflections really nice
reflections
you love to see it
another thing that i love
is the
like displacement
in the tile on the columns
how they're like top lit and you can
really see them all poking oh yeah
you're right you're right
such a beautiful little detail it's a
beautiful texture you got a nice little
sim going a little bug a little bug
going by oh there's a bug boy where's
that where's the bug at on the right
dude a little cockroach
a little bud
hello is that and the robot's asking for
oil got a little oil can on it just like
yeah look at this
yeah it's a simple one you did a real
nice job of locking off your scene
you're not talking about any background
we're just talking about foreground here
and you're doing a perfect job the car
and the person walking by top notch
and having that and having that annoying
light right like it's a you can tell
some annoying advertisement on the right
just like a great detail that really
grounds it makes it feel like a lived-in
space oh yeah the neon flash that's so
cool
i say my one oh my one note
it'd be interesting to see that window
on the left like
maybe some sort of light or maybe just a
reflection of something on the other on
the backside of camera through that
window on the left to balance the darker
side
yeah i can see that
very small though very small otherwise
what cool what a cool just what a cool
wet environment yeah
igor
probably the right who knows
pronunciation but congrats to you got
you rendered a real nice point in the
music too it's gonna be great
it's gonna be awesome arm on
is next
kid's face dude
i had that clock dude
that clock on that clock on the top left
yeah i had that clock growing up that
was my alarm clock i'm not even kidding
it's crazy they did a really good job of
like
of okay what does that mean you might be
able to ask this or answer this on the
bottom left the two hd
box what is that i know i've seen that
left fujifilm 2 hd
you see that little box is to the right
of the of the toy story ball
oh i can't even see it it's very dark
okay yeah
it's like laser discs or something
this is so much fun wow they really
nailed the mortal kombat look by the way
yeah crushed it all the detail and like
the game system
cartridges
oh and then you know what's fun about
that it's like notice the story here the
kid does it and then the door opens up
it's like the parents are coming home or
or heard him right it's so much fun yeah
i got caught playing games late at night
yeah
it's getting a [ __ ] perfect
just a perfect score dude not even hit
once
look at that
kid knows how to play video games what's
up hype armond congratulations beautiful
scene you put out here lots of heart
into it i wonder if this guy's a dad and
he's like i'm gonna make a render
like from my childhood and maybe he has
a son or something
i'd be curious oh yeah you're very
curious
um
hd high density floppy disks that's what
that's oh okay floppy disks
got you got you
confirmed
confirmed
oh
wallace
oh and it's good
oh it's so much fun mm-hmm
oh it hits a button oh that's so much
fun
oh i didn't see the button that's great
and a bit of cheese grommet
yeah this one's sick they're they're um
their shaders and their textures are
scaled correctly to feel like a
miniature scene like like we were saying
earlier once again yeah yeah
and also like you know the the the
choppiness right the no motion blur
really yeah wow yeah the no motion blur
is actually perfect usually i would say
there needs to be motion blur every time
but
in this case it's perfect without it
i love it i love i love when they i mean
i love it it's gotta be blender right
when i'm but like blenders i've seen
these like claymation looking things in
blender just so cool to me yeah yeah a
lot of people
got that claymation look figured out in
blender
[Music]
super nice yeah benjamin very very good
job
great render great lighting
oh
rainer
the creepiest yep puppet yep
ever made
yeah
the crap's so creeped out by this puppet
dude i know it's creepy to me as well
it's a clown that must be a clown like
slapping the dog
yeah
you don't want to wake up with this one
looking over you you know
but that environment though those shoes
the pants like
i love how the character has
their weight to one hip you know it's a
very very subtle
thing but
if you pan if you dollied up or if you
pan uh craned up no money in that
suitcase
too scary
but it's also like really a little gut i
think there's a gunshot through the
window there it's like not a not a
pixar neighborhood let's put it that way
that's fair yeah that's fair
so creepy
ah it's so creepy
hello
hey you know what's crazy is that uh you
know
he doesn't have a string on to
manipulate the mouth opening that's the
doll doing on so god it feels like
almost like a blue screen of a real
person
like added into this
it's creepy yeah it's gross
in like in the best of ways in the best
in the best ways but creepy good job
creepy render
rainer solid stuff
um
yoga lin
monkey king
who's this oh yeah that's my boy like
super monkey advanced monkey king
dude he leveled up
those little warriors too
yeah
so in the in the myth actually
uh
someone will come would summon them by
plucking his hairs and turning his hairs
into the uh into the monsters or the you
know his allies yeah
so not historically accurate this one
[Laughter]
do you know what's going on in the
background like is that is that those
are the gods man those are the gods
coming in and being like yo you crazy
monkey king what are you doing
they're not they're not a fan of this
he's he's about to go to war against the
heavens itself dude
that hand reaching out on the top right
is so good
yeah
really awesome scene
yeah reminds me like cut scene out of a
game or something
yeah a little bit a little bit
yoga limb
those those gods are ready to fight like
look at the background he's pulling his
sword up like they're ready to throw
down
yeah really really good job on their
movement too like if they were moving
any faster it wouldn't feel right but
getting that slow-mo look going is
perfect
really nice
good stuff congrats on that top 100
gatson
ooh good water
now see this is a pretty wet render this
one feels pretty wet sloshing for sure
that's sloshing that little halo effect
of the water is you get it an arc right
here yeah and then the and then the
little bits of it dissipate out
do not trip and fall this is next to a
cliff do not trip and fall here yeah
that sim is sick though
it has a cool water sip mm-hmm
oh the nice little life stones i was
just gonna say yeah i just noticed that
yeah a little graystone little little
little animal a little like stuffed fit
animal maybe for
yeah that that makes it
that makes it interesting a little more
depth just a little more depth just a
little more you know visual interest
really good story subtle story there
solid stuff
gaston not gatson gaston
rock on rock on
yeah very cool
andre oh this one's so good what is oh
my
goodness oh this is
this is so wide there's a wild one
look how happy they are getting singed
up they're all getting singed
ooh that's great on the texture that
looks very much like marshmallows
getting seen just really good i know
right
and like the fact that they're like
all about it makes it
makes it work if they were like
screaming in pain it would not be cool
but like look at him he's all tucked up
on the right all cozy dude who could you
imagine going over clint what's for uh
dinner i got you marshmallows and bell
peppers dude
i'm like oh you hungry dog we got
marshmallows and peps
tonight's gonna be the night dude
s'mores and
oh no this is this one this one
unsettles me in the way that i didn't
know i could be unsettled mm-hmm
yeah trapped man the lighting is so good
the under light oh there's like a look
in this his foot gets stuck too right
little
big old gummy
[Music]
so this one's scary
should i move on
oh yeah he's like doing a little fly oh
my gosh
i love it yeah amazing it's creepy
really good stuff andre i love this one
so much
great work
on keats
whoa
fight club action
yeah
beautiful lighting
i am all about this robot carrying on
the left there snack box just doing its
job you know just going around and being
like anybody hungry
yeah it's so good
literally this fight wasn't a good one
because you see people leaving at the
very start of it
three people being like we're done we're
good
uh it's crazy that they managed to get
drake in the crowd the guy the orange on
the left
the guy drinking
yeah yeah yeah
yeah it's actually
you get the scan and everything's a lot
of work
oh he's doubled up on the right
you got two drakes dude yeah oh my gosh
yeah i think also the lady here on the
left clapping we see her twice on the
left with the uh shorts yeah you gotta
break them up break them up a little bit
i think at first viewing
you're you're pretty good you're not
gonna ever know this yeah it's just
background crowd yeah
but it is solid job you know you need a
big crowd um
well it feels like a fight it feels like
a fight because the robot's you know
handing out refreshments
agreed
that refreshment bot makes it
that refreshing bro 100 makes it it
grounds it into just being like yep
there's also robots who's just doing
some work yup just like so much fun
normal situation
good stuff on keat i love it love that
lighting
super cool character too
good sodium feelings great grimy and
grungy yeah
francisco
whoa
alice wonderland theme
great use of the mocap like perfect
perfect scene for it you know having
everything flow by the camera she just
kind of has everything pass over
very true takes on the like the the very
trippy the takes on the on the rabbit
being realistic and the the hookah worm
being like mr
like freeze
showing up with the
wow super trippy this is a place i would
never want to visit
yeah
true a little damp it's a little bit
damp a little bit more like uh
what's the word i'm looking for
i don't even know it's just the feeling
of
cataclysm yeah it's got kind of a tim
burton-esque kind of feel to it too like
a little askew the colors and stuff just
a little creepy
what's with all these creepy ones at the
end
i don't know what about the offset the
creep factor
very cool though very cool very cool one
yeah good composition
really nice
yeah just like little and all the just
additional bits of animation right the
rabbit the hookah guy little cloth on
the right just always just something to
look at pretty cool agreed yeah a lot of
details always it's so impressive to
watch these over and over and see all
these little details so much work
so much work goes in all this like i
said at the beginning of the stream
literal decades worth of community work
on these um
yeah it's nuts good stuff yeah francisco
uh this next guy
is named mustafa
bug
whoa yup this one goes with cockroach
world right
yeah this is like the price
oh it's like i'm just it's just there's
so many little things going on here
a little big droplet of water coming
down mm-hmm
the old goopy can or something
some nasty old like
sea canned clams or something
and the secondary legs right additional
animation to get the legs yeah
totally
i love this their lighting is great too
it's very dappled and spot lit
yeah yeah yeah
yeah great use of like
shadows in the light you know maybe
putting like a little
thing in front of it to kind of break it
up
cool
grade yeah really nice color very punchy
very saturated
solid stuff mustafa killing it
killing it
a little belt too little red belt thing
ah yes there we go here's our first
non-black belt that's great little sam
on there too
good stuff good stuff mustafa very cool
oh this one
this one's so good
yeah the way the gravity's affected when
she brings it in like here
that's not all at once right it's like
it's from it's from the back to the
front
and you're seeing right all the stuff
being pulled from the wall goes from the
back to the front oh yeah first you know
it's not all at the same time which is
really cool very cool using like you
know the newspaper to cover
the uh the
the window so you still get a little bit
of like daylight peeking in through
there
but it doesn't distract because i mean
it's the perfect move it would be these
blinding white spots of attention trying
to steal your attention from the
character but
you know you you patched them up
the variety of objects right so you have
these heavy objects but then you have
the cloth and the little things on
chains swinging around on the left right
wow
this one feels right the weight feels
right on this one
look at the bag
it's punched it's so cool yeah am i
right in saying that we're looking
through a mirror here we are
yeah i was a little confused at first
but yeah oh to try and emphasize the
feeling and the look of the punch we're
seeing both sides of that bag oh
interesting
oh and it cracks the window on the way
in
[Music]
see now this is one of those situations
where that's probably a realistic crack
right realistic in terms of how much is
diffracting
but but since we're in the since we're
in a weird realm right it feels like you
want to try and emphasize that crap more
right more artificially
ultra or just more like more of
jaggedness right than you'd expect just
to make sure that you know this that
it's happening but like giving it
through the mirror allowing you to see
both sides of the punch is really cool
you know what it needed it needed pieces
of the glass to fall off the wall to
reveal the concrete with like the gum oh
that's cool
yeah it needed a little bit
but like wow there's just so much going
on in this one i i love the way that the
feeling of force gets transmitted
through the background animations
agreed
yeah you feel it and even in the
air particulate it moves with the energy
of the scene it's not footage yeah such
a clever
such a clever idea to have this desk
with a piece of cloth on it so that when
it gets pulled the cloth can go more and
react back and it goes back the clock is
just like emphasizing that's so cool
what is what a clever idea yeah this
one's this one's absolutely incredible
huge fan really good
car is next
beautiful render you got
i like to think that this is straight up
what is the front of an airplane
that's the front of an airplane the
boxiest airplane ever made it's funny
definitely get do dubai vibes um at
least oh yeah from what i've seen i've
never been there but
a lot of verticality too interesting use
of like verticality and once again right
you get a sense of what the differing
weights of these pieces of bamboo are
because of how they're reacting
right the the one on the third the one
on the third one from the left second
one from the right that one definitely
feels like it's heavier the number two
and number four
right feel lighter
it's such a good way to like
doing these like as i was watching this
i was like man
they're they're people are doing such a
good job of having the environment
react especially that last one
with um different like attractors and
and yeah
gravity and stuff and force
everyone's doing such a good job with
that and to add that balloon dude that
balloon up there like
i don't know if they were like i need
something there to fill it but
that color contrast is perfect
yeah yeah yeah it's a good color cut
dress
heck yeah
car amazing
amazing
kirby
brutal oh cool
yeah i love the uniqueness of this one
the 2d anime the character is awesome
i'm a cat too
mom left
no kidding
we were talking about this when we were
watching
uh when we were when we were selecting
the top 100 we realized
though this one is top 100 quality
it doesn't need this
black
like street running by the frame here
cause you don't know i like the
i think it's it's so fast i think it's
supposed to be like the garbage maybe or
something i think it's the cat running
by but it doesn't it's not important to
tell this oh is that the cat oh it is
the cat you're right
assuming but like
it is it is it is a cat it is a cat for
sure
maybe it needed to be a little further
away from the camera or something
because it just looks like or maybe just
a few more frames of it yeah something
yeah there's the cat yeah you're right
cool though cool cool that like the
stuff on the ground you think it's just
like oh yeah that's just a faked into
the texture nope
that's real yeah love it
such a good way to show the force
the energy from the character interact
with that environment
yeah i love this one that's the biggest
manhole cover i've ever seen in my life
holy crap
that's true oh my goodness you're right
jeez
solid stuff kirby congrats on top 100.
we are getting close to the end here
we're getting very close
and we will reveal the top five
kid yaya is next
good lighting on that mm-hmm the
material just like i can't stop looking
at the cloth there
it feels like so starched right
like it feels like you can it feels like
you could
grasp the texture of that claw through
your fingers
you got that the water moving around
yeah
super solid i think what a lot of people
are doing
is using cloth
sims on their characters to
hide
some of the uh inconsistencies that you
might see in the mocap data
so it actually makes it look
a lot more fluid by having these cloth
symbols over top the characters and
it's a great it's such a great way to to
do it really cleans it up nice
yeah yeah
here's the thing i think they needed
though like
you see how the mid ground
looks a little muddy and like kind of
just same same
yeah i feel like they needed like a
giant flag
above and out of frame to really darken
the mid ground
way more
you know
i see or or maybe give give some little
you know push push a little bit with
these like stones you know is there a
glow there is there but that's really
cool though i see yeah totally yeah
because because the dragon's eye glows
and it does it looks like they do get a
little bit of a glow
yeah a little bit of color movement but
yeah and the dragon's like you can see
it's starting to wake up it's starting
to break out from
that shadow that break is when he does
this move right here it's like he moves
to the
yeah so he pulls it down oh interesting
yeah yeah i feel like this one could
like maybe just use like
15 percent 20 more of environment
reaction to the characters because
they're like kind of doing it but it's
just just below the amount for it to be
like
really noticeable a choice right a
choice yeah
yeah
but i mean cool obviously it's it's top
100 so can't say much more than that uh
kid yaya very very good stuff very
peaceful i got yours in a very cool spot
in the montage as well so
like i said like i keep saying next
weekend top 100 montage is popping off
custom music by my very good friend
feverkin is going to be amazing
cool
oh oh my goodness wow
this looks
this
looks looks real yeah this looks real
wow
this is la
high toe
this is this okay so this is another
example of that that render engine it's
that look that lighting look that
it looks real it's like the it's even
like the the the monster is kind of
moving up a little bit the guy's like oh
my god no yup he's like breathing
wild
perfect justification
for the mocap like why are you doing tai
chi oh it's a sweet end pose move for
you know this episode that you just shot
yeah
wow
it really nails the look of what it
looks like on set for these for like
these super sentai shows too
you're talking like with the lights and
the boom and like yeah with the trash no
no just the way that the it's a top lit
kind of flat studio environment right
the tendency here i think would be to go
for like you know more dramatic lighting
but no these these shows look like this
so sick it's cool yeah big fan of this
one
the haito
maybe i'm
butchering that but
congrats this is great
freaking awesome really cool
grant
got you next
huh that's great i just realized they
have a little text at the bottom that
says the ad will end in
and they have like a little countdown
oh it's like an ad oh yeah yeah
feels like i'm on a i'm on a little
spaceship or like a ship traveling
through
it feels like that with the camera move
it does feel like that oh yeah yeah the
camera move interesting
yeah this is a cool very blade runner of
course
yeah that the the the uh the animation
looks like it's a photo like right it's
like a photorealistic video of a person
that's been run through that yeah yeah
yeah that's cool yeah i dig it really
nice
like design here on the technology you
have this like little screen thing on
the or the on the bottom right this
panel on the bottom right with a plug
that goes up into this
this projector you know this uh what's
the right word i'm failing to find the
right word but it's like 3d projector or
some kind yeah hologram projector
hologram that's right yeah
yeah and lots of little character things
here on the on the right you got some
pills you got
character and his wife beer chinese food
the good stuff
the good stuff
amazing
very cool yeah good stuff grant
jamie
perfect
those fun super oh wow the super hot
vibes yes perfect
great use of the mocap data
justifies it
wow
yeah a good physics sim on the right
with the boxes and stuff i love the very
simple
just concrete you know
um very much like the game but they're
doing a great job
yeah a little more fidelity than the
game
there's a little more more polygons
oh yeah
oh and just again having played the game
right really subtle thing to make sure
that when the tech shows up it's you
know it's it's it it it's like polar
warped and then it comes in
yeah they did a good job with this one
wow
beautiful colors and the lighting of the
bullets as it passes by the black
reflective right
cool
wow cool
sick jamie congrats on top 100
wow we only have a couple more
hassan
boom
look at that water yeah this one feels
so lush
very lush
it's almost weird enough i get a
miniature feel i think it's just a scale
of the water but like yeah
wow yeah so on that pop i love the pop
of the of the model here right here
getting that kicking the thing off right
kicking the cloth off
using the using the animation
of the cloth to further emphasize your
motion your movement right
cool yeah this one's classic very
classic monk meditating practicing tai
chi in the forest but it's done well i
love the water sims
the lighting in the background is really
hot highlights feels great
temple up there
a little subtle thing in the motion
capture data right there's a little tiny
weight adjustment there right when he
goes up on one foot
right it goes up and there's a little
adjustment there
for weight that's the kind of stuff that
i think i really i love that when you
see it's what you can get from real
motion and movement you know yeah it
makes the biggest difference like you
can actually see it a lot on uh on this
one
as well like i think you can see it more
so
oh yeah yeah a little like just trying
to sell correct
self-correction yeah yeah anyway
that's good
shout outs to lou
blue june chang
did all the mocap performances for us he
did uh he worked on shang chi did a lot
of the choreography with chris uh young
yeah
yeah i just those water's so lush
like it's just
like it's just like cold glacial runoff
just all the elements of it up front and
the back yeah
what dunk my head in that this one's
fresh very very fresh
very crisp and fresh
all right
we got one more
one more
who's it gonna be
it's our boy zeus creates an og on the
server
oh the dock goes down my gosh
oh the duck goes down
that's the best that's so nice dude
that's a good boy
what an amazing scene
yeah little point caustics and stuff
yeah really cool
beautiful the the the design on the
environment the amount of detail that
goes into
this environment they got the bruce lee
water interview going on too on the tv
i love also that you know that this is
like a little kid because the chair
right
oh the chair's bigger huh
yeah that's that's what i'm reading it
as i'm reading that's like a little kid
a little mischievous kid and that's the
brother or the parent coming in to be
like stop making the dog play dead yeah
exactly up in the attic just
having a good old time
this one's beautiful
oh the subtle yin yang on the clock
top center oh yeah you're right look at
that
yeah this one this one is freaking
beautiful
they got all the greats too they got
avatar cowboy bebop death note and then
it says secret you see it says secret
dojo
where
on the on the uh arch on the top of the
arch right here
secret secret dojo for just a quick
second
that's great
um beautiful
zeus creates hats off to you you
knocked it out of the park
and that's it y'all that is it
that's the top 100 each and every one of
you guys if you saw your art here you
uh
you got a kit bash 3d kit of your choice
they will be in touch
all right we're going to get your kits
and we have to announce next here we
have to announce
the top
five winners so
i mean do we do do we just get into it
or do we uh i think we get into that
first of all i've been i was very
impressed with everybody's work here
just very cool it's also a challenging
camera move too right like it's not your
sort of typical flat scene there's a
little movement to it you know i think
that's that's there's a little bit of an
element there that you know various
people took on to try and use the camera
a little bit to try and
bring together all the elements but just
a lot of really great work
overall
uh and look if you didn't see your stuff
doesn't mean that doesn't mean your work
isn't good because your work art is
about expressing yourself right
and a big part of it
is if you're finding fulfillment and
you're finding progress in your own work
that's that's you can only say that's
good right that's only net positive so
that's you know i think
this is a lifelong pursuit our art
itself is a lifelong pursuit and i think
that these the way things are being
expressed here all things that you can
just take absorb bring into your own
work and continue to iterate and improve
on your own work
absolutely yeah i mean i'll double down
on what you said freddie like if your
guys stuff wasn't in the top 100 it's
okay
um it's about what you learned along the
way and if you grew and if you had fun
that's what counts and i know that if
you got through this and if you
completed some art i guarantee you'll
learn some stuff like you know
and there will be more opportunities
next time
i think what it just comes down to is
you're doing this for a reason you're
doing this because it's your passion and
you want to get better at it and that's
why we're here on this channel
we're working and here's how you know
that it has to be passionate because
it's too much work if it wasn't right
it's one thing to be like yeah i'll just
you know crank out something for a thing
but if it's like you see how much
there's like even the most basic stuff
requires so much work
and so much effort that goes into it you
have to be passionate about it which is
nice because then you look around you're
like cool everyone here is passionate
about this that's always a good feeling
agreed yeah and these montages are such
a great example of that
um so you know as you all know we're
going to announce the winners here in
the next couple minutes
um next week the top the top 100 montage
comes out next week my my good buddy
fever can
put together an incredible soundtrack
he's wrapping up the details now i've
chosen all the specific places for every
specific render throughout the entire 10
and a half minutes worth of music and
he's adding little bits to really spice
up and make it feel like every render
belongs truly to that one point in the
music oh cool yeah dude it's the
soundtrack is so cool i i can't wait for
you guys to hear it
um and then the week after that we're
gonna release the all renders montage
which has all the renders minus the ones
that either
broke
the montage broke the animation
um or were just out of place or your
your technical
uh deliveries were just too far off i
really did try
to take everyone like take everyone's
stuff and bring it together really i i
went through everything
and try to conform it as much as
possible but some of them some of you
all you got to check your exports please
check her out
oh man um mason uh shout outs to you
grant thank you so much i see you in the
chat there with the super chats thank
you um
bendadi thank you very very much y'all
are very kind thank you so much uh for
the support devon shoe i see you
thank you thank you um
apologies if i missed anyone but y'all
are awesome uh grant you say everyone
should be proud of their work yes they
should glad i was able to participate in
this challenge thank you clint the mods
for organizing everything freddy thanks
for for joining me on this man yeah
definitely freaking awesome um this was
so great
shall we do it shall we announce the
five the five winners do it hit the five
all right all right all right all right
all right all right let me queue this up
here
let me queue this up
all right so
switch over
bum bum bum this is the moment y'all
been waiting for here we go
so if you came
in
fifth place which we're about to
announce right now
you get a total of three kit bash kits
of your choice
as well as a perpetual davinci resolve
studio license
none of this monthly subscription stuff
you just get it davinci is the best i
use it freddy are you on davinci we we
just switched over heck yeah
yeah it's the best it's the best
um so without further ado i am proud to
announce fifth place for the moving
meditations challenge
anna
oh yeah
so cool
so
freaking great like
i hadn't seen a time lapse render like
this
to this level since we've been doing
these challenges
it's it's perfect so much detail went
into this you have all these characters
coming in all these little moments
happening with this character
um
it takes so much work to get this done
and
you knocked it out like for real you
knocked it out
i really like this one
such a wealth of detail
and and and just different things and
that the lighting and the evolution of
the scene
uh
yeah i
yeah
just stunning
um it's a it's emotional too like i feel
i feel something when i watch this
um yeah
yeah you're you're firing on all
cylinders so anna
congratulations we will be in touch with
you on the prizes
um and we hope to get you here on the
live stream
a little bit later and talk to you about
your process
um i believe in october we're going to
try and
try and get the winners
on and we'll talk about their process so
i'm very excited for you thank you so
much for putting your hard work into it
you earned it
um next up
fourth place now fourth place you get
the same thing okay
you get uh
the three kit bash kits and you also get
the perpetual davinci resolve studio
license
and we have
in fourth place
christian
oh yeah
yes
dude i love this one
so much
so so much yeah the stylisticness of
this one the
the reveal of this this these little
creatures and the sort of story that's
implied
beautiful
yeah it feels very unique
like
another one this is a this is another
like really it's not super emotional but
i do feel something with it like this
one just makes me happy
well it's also to me it's like it's all
the the fact that they're all wearing
little masks and you have one even in
the crowd turn around to be like hey
what's going back here right this guy
let's see this one in green turns around
to follow to follow the birds or the
little butterflies rather that that fly
towards a fly towards camera um
yeah it's just like there's so much
detail into that it's fascinating agreed
yeah agreed please keep it up christian
go ahead yeah
yeah no i'm just saying it's just a
beautiful environment agreed man
um
congrats christian fourth place amazing
i i can't wait to also have you on talk
about your process get your little
breakdown on this
it's gonna be amazing thank you so much
for putting all your hard work into it
you earned it
and uh i can't wait to see what you do
next all right
third place
third place
very curious
what do they get they get a tablet too
right yeah so third place gets the three
kit bash kits you get the perpetual
davinci studio resolve license
and in a wacom intuos pro tablet size of
your choice
um i've loved these tablets they've
saved my wrist
i want to be able to do this work for a
long time and uh yeah i can work long
hours with this thing and
it's great i've been using for a long
time anyway
let's get to it coming in third place
for the moving meditations 3d community
challenge we have
dimitri
with this beautiful
beautiful
beautiful environment
so dramatic with these characters frozen
in time like this
like pompeii but like maxed out like
oh man you really feel the impact we
were saying of this one right you you
you almost hear this one in your head
just the cool caustics especially on the
lens too catching the bottom left a
little bit of like a the flare coming
through and rippling through
i love like the subtle details here with
the film green on top
the lighting it feels real it feels like
i can be here the glow of the foreground
all the detail that you have in the
foreground the glow picks that up so
nicely and these 2d elements that you're
bringing in they're designed beautifully
you're bringing them into 3d and kind of
warping them and making them feel 2.5 a
little bit
that that little rune thing the
animation as it comes up and the way it
glows like that's that's commercial like
right that's that's commercial aaa movie
quality
yeah agreed agreed it's some really
really good like hud design kind of
stuff yeah yeah it's very difficult to
do
but your lighting like right right off
the top
that lighting you're using where it's
right about like morning or
almost night time is a really cool vibe
to the stars up there your planet is
awesome
yeah this is this is beautiful work
congratulations
yeah
absolutely amazing so enjoy that way
coming to us pro tablet enjoy your kit
bash packs enjoy that davinci studio
resolve license and i hope to see you on
the stream
uh pretty soon here we'll talk about
your workflow give us a little breakdown
of how you did this
thank you so much
all right second and first
oh it's coming down to it
all right
so this second place
um
is
get the suit and everything else already
right oh yeah yeah you get everything
and you get the rococo suit you get the
the um
smartsuit pro 2 their brand new suit um
better in every way
and we hope it helps you make some cool
renders in the future
so without further ado coming in second
place
we have our very own
zeus
creates
this beautiful render
so much detail went into this
the posters to the boxes to the
furniture
to the design of your scene the lighting
is perfect
it looks incredible there's story going
on
there's emotion there's feeling with the
character
gorgeous absolutely gorgeous
such good work
amazing amazing i can't wait to see how
you went through this how you did this
talk to you about your process
we hope you enjoy that mocap suit
it's gonna be awesome
dude yes congratulations zeus you earned
it knocked it out of the park
all right
great use of lighting too raise the
practical sources great use of i think
there's a lot more subtlety here too
that goes and work that goes into making
sure that your eye isn't just
overwhelmed and that your eyes drawn to
the right places for this one as well
agreed yeah agreed um it's very nice
little spotlight in the foreground
because you did a great job you
you took on the challenge of filling out
a very dense
cluttered space and you knocked it out
and like freddie said you are really
choosing and lighting the scene well so
that you're not getting overwhelmed by
all the stuff that is in your scene
um
and the more you watch it the more you
can kind of like
pick up on the things you enjoy and find
out all your little details it's very
clear how much work went into this scene
so you should be very very very proud of
yourself
congratulations
zeus creates
all right that only leaves one spot
freddie at least once yeah it's got a
number one
let's see it this full bro between
capture bundle and everything else oh
man i can't wait the whole the whole one
number one
number one
is i don't want to mess up this name
it's in a compound clip so it doesn't
say the name but i believe it's andrus x
with this
insane alien render
boom
oh
photo realistic it is
bigger than life it's you're doing
things that's not just
recreating real life but you are
bringing this sci-fi other natural
aspect to it and that lady gets screwed
up pretty hard too oh destroyed dude
to me this one had i think such a great
sense of impact
right like it really does feel just so
strong on that yeah it's one of the
what's
real quick what's fascinating is right
there's a lot of them that do that right
they did like this this motion that
gives an impact to it
note for those of you who are trying to
learn from this note it's the exact same
bass animation but look at how different
the impact feels across all of these
different entries right it's the same
animation but some of them are like this
felt
more impactful so sometimes right it's
sometimes you can be like well it's not
quite hitting what it is maybe we gotta
re-record it's like think about what are
the other elements at play here that are
adding to that feeling of impact a lot
of times it's not the it's not the
animation because everyone had the same
animation right but there was a
different feel across all of that
absolutely yeah it is it's a great idea
a fantastic idea and executed perfectly
the from the
the lighting to the rendering to the
shifts in the lighting to the textures
the materials the reflection off the
tile on the walls the tile uh like rigid
body simulation from them smacking into
the walls
oh man so much so much goes into this
the brow and the alien the blank
the detail's insane andrus
congratulations my goodness i cannot
wait to have you on stream talk about
this figure out your process
and congrats to all the artists
everybody who submitted thank you so
much if it wasn't for you guys
putting your hardest and best work into
this montage or into these challenges
they just wouldn't be as cool so thank
you guys so so much for doing this for
putting all the blood sweat and tears
into this
just hopefully this inspires you guys
don't get discouraged if you didn't make
it if you didn't win keep it up please
please keep it up i love what you guys
are doing the community loves what
you're doing
um and uh you know just keep climbing
keep climbing
so yeah
freddy um
we've been at it for a while now um
you are
uh happy to bounce here i know it's been
a minute i'm probably going to hang out
with the chat here and maybe do a little
yeah no yeah yeah q a yeah i got some
work to do this weekend another working
weekend for me but yeah same man this
was so much fun
i just i loved seeing the breadth and
depth of the work
and
you know i think that that's
you know i think when you're when you're
when you're trying this out you know i
think that like don't be afraid
to
really let your mind go wild with some
of this stuff right like you see the
range of the stuff that we're dealing
with even though it's the same animation
i think that that's the to me it's your
chance to try something outside your
comfort zone to try something that you'd
be like you know go go deep in your
order of thoughts like you'd be like
it's you know there's like first order
be like oh it's a thing it might be this
you know you you might come your your
first thought try even do anything which
is like throw away the first 10 ideas
you have just go with number 11. try try
going way deep and maybe you know like
when you go that way i think the the
deeper you go the more outside the
comfort zone that you're going to be and
the more you're in that space the faster
you learn
agreed yeah get through all the get
through all the bad ideas first you know
just know that you're going to have bad
ideas and you're not going to go with
the first one write it down and i
wouldn't even say bad they're not even
bad ideas right it would just be
it would just be this
know that the first thing that comes to
your head
is comfortable right because you're
never gonna if you just go with
immediate first thought for something
it's always gonna be a comfortable
thought right because that's just where
you're that's where that's how you're
wired the moment that you're pushing
yourself to be like all right now throw
those throws all the way go even weirder
go deeper that by definition is going to
put you out of your comfort zone
yeah that's very good advice very very
good advice
um yeah i it's so cool freddie like
i've known you for so long and if again
if it weren't for you i wouldn't be out
here in la i you gave me a job when i
first came out here you helped me learn
yeah
like um
it's it's just been an absolute
pleasure and an honor knowing you and
and to have you man and come here and
dish out some good inspiration for
everybody is yeah i think i think
everybody should be proud everybody who
participates should be proud of what
they did everybody who didn't
participate
i can't say you should be proud but you
should try it next time give it a shot
next time get in there yeah it's the
perfect way to learn it's the perfect
way to learn there's no there's no
stakes there's only really wind stuff i
guess
um but y'all thank you freddie thank you
i'm gonna hang with the audience here
thanks so much yeah yeah all right man
thanks so much for having me really
appreciate it thanks everybody for
watching i hang out with clint for a
little bit i got some other work to do
but it was a pleasure watching all of
these and and just seeing the just how
much creativity and how much just kind
of interesting things i feel like i've
learned quite a bit about 3d just by
watching even though i didn't even
participate right so this is this is
really great
thank you freddie catch you soon thank
you so much man see you later man
bye
good stuff everybody amazing stuff wow
this is a crazy moment i i i'd be
curious to see how you all feel right
now
um personally
it feels great to
the challenge isn't done for me i still
have work to do still got to finish the
top 100 still got to finish the all
renders
and it goes on to my art breakdown and
into the winners interviews that we'll
have on stream later in october so
you know these challenges are a lot of
work to set up i got to give a shout out
to my moderators
um everybody who who really pushes it
and helps out from coming up with the
ideas to the challenges to helping
moderate chat building the faqs
building the different uh project files
and whatnot
we're talking sonamonte we're talking
visual mdk ronin scipo
saipo is huge because he does a lot of
the back end stuff he makes the google
form set up in a way that like all of
the submissions come in
in a very specific naming order so it's
like your name your instagram et cetera
et cetera so that we can do an automatic
titles thing so i don't have to sit here
and type everyone's name out so sipo
shout outs to you did i forget anyone
soda we got soto mbk visual cypo
ronin i don't think oh
connor
and connor helping out in the chat
giving people a sense of like
where you should be at he does a really
really good job of um
kind of guiding people and and giving
them an idea of where you should be at
by the weeks you build out a whole like
schedule like a a general schedule for
people so it really helped everybody out
um
but i'm looking at the chat right now if
you guys want to say something to me hit
me with a punisher in the chat there's a
lot of you know a lot of people in here
so
seeing the at punisher really helps me
kind of pick out some questions i think
there are some super chats that i may
have missed
let's see
um
will clark yes
says hell yeah well deserved good job
everyone thank you for the super chat
will
this is very kind of you thanks for
the uh the support and giving your
praise to everybody in the chat here
um will jane any honorable mentions
honorable mentions all right so the way
we've done it in the past is like um
we the first time we did this we
actually had like a
a list of
top 75 top 50 top 25 top 15 in the top
five and it just took forever took way
too long
um there were a number of ones that came
really really close um to top five
and i have
most of them marked
i can kind of give shout outs to a
couple of them
um
i don't but i don't want to forget
anybody you know i don't want to give
any like
you know preferential treatment if i
didn't shout you out then i don't want
you to think that yours wasn't good
um
but i'll i can go through a couple here
and just kind of give some shout outs to
ones that i that i enjoyed i think this
first one
right off the bat uh
is
is beautiful it's a very beautiful
buttery scene there isn't really any
jank to it
it's nice and creamy as nathaniel i
really liked it loved your lighting love
your color
we have uh jaeger here
let's see jaeger where you at
i thought this one was beautifully lit
beautifully animated
um
for the winners i tried to go for stuff
that didn't have existing ip i think it
takes a little bit
more to
develop a custom character custom worlds
but you really knocked out the park man
like you were definitely up there
um what else let's see
i don't want to forget anybody you know
um
yeah top five
uh this one here yeah by shang
this one came
super super close
for me i think it's one of the best
looking environments the most detailed
vast environment you know people are
doing kind of close-ups blocking things
off with walls but this this depth just
goes and
boy i want to be here in this world
so so beautiful you came super close
mitch mitch i i i saw you too
you came pretty close i this render is
just beautiful
i love it so much
the fog the reveal the like the emotion
in it
like this character's almost pleading
ah so good so so good this one the
lighting was beautiful i really dug the
lighting here um
the idea too is super cool
but just this image this image right
here is insane i love that lighting so
much so beautiful
um
this one yeah top five
first place
this one came this one i i i took
another look at this one you know like
this one i thought was very interesting
really nice environment nice atmosphere
i dug this one a lot
um
this one very close as well you know
um
i love it it's very near and dear to me
love me some ghibli
this one came close
what else
you know there there were maybe a couple
others i don't have them marked
in here in front of me right now but um
because there's a couple like in here
there's a couple sleepers in here that
that i really really enjoyed
see if i just land on any one of them
yeah there are some solid ones
but y'all like freddy was saying you
know don't be discouraged if you didn't
get in the top 100 don't be discouraged
if you didn't win i understand if you do
feel that way though
um
you know you feel like you really had a
shot at it but you didn't get it
i got you i understand it's tough that's
tough
um but just you should be very proud of
yourself
for submitting something that you guys
are very proud of you should be very
very proud of yourself
um
i'm going back to the chat here let's
see what y'all are saying we got some
app punishers here
when's the next challenge
stay tuned subscribe to find out
if you ain't subscribed already y'all
better subscribe we hit a million
uh like a month ago literally on my
birthday we hit a million which is crazy
uh how am i doing today you're not
feeling good honestly i'm feeling good
that the challenge is mostly over the
hard work is over
um i'm going to be going to camp mograph
later this year or sorry not like this
here
two weeks from now and then i'm going to
half res in chicago next week
so i gotta wrap up the top 100 wrap up
the all renders um and
kind of go on like a mini work vacation
so i'm very excited about that it feels
good to to get through this and be done
and dish out the prizes so much goes
into all this guys
so much
all right
can you know if your particip if your
participation was disqualified
i don't know
the best way
to
dish out that info like technically how
to do so because there are a handful of
them maybe 300 plus that
didn't make it because
the camera was just freaking upside down
or sideways or left or right or
your animation was 800 frames long and
where your character was on the top of
the frame it just broke the animation
which is so you all got please check
please check to see if your files are
looking good in the end
um before you upload
but there's so many in the all renders
there's like tons um sypo one of the
moderators he's going to actually have
we're going to build out a google sheet
you can search your name in the google
sheet and it'll actually show you a time
code and if your render is not in there
it's probably because it was one of
those like just technically too far gone
to make it into the challenge and it's
brutal
to cut those out because i know you all
put work in
and it's probably the hardest for those
people
um because
you feel like you're excluded from this
big community event um
but just take it as a learning lesson
to please check your stuff please please
please
check your frame rate check your
resolution check your aspect ratio
check that your
your render lines up with the template
renders like that's so important um
and maybe something i'll
double down on a triple quadruple down
on
for the next challenge like
maybe give some uh
some things maybe make a video on like
really make sure that this is your final
render because if not it can be cut from
the montage and that's it you know we
don't want that
uh brian you're welcome for yeah
absolutely um
i'm glad that you guys enjoyed these
challenges
let's see scrolling down looking at the
chat here
matthew what's up hey you've been a
patreon supporter thank you so much for
that and you're thinking about trying
the next challenge that's what's up man
so
for those of you who
want to get into 3d
and who want to get better at 3d i got
the perfect thing for you
so on the discord server we got the link
in the description
we have weekly challenges every single
week there's a new challenge i believe
the prompt this week is mundane
so you got to make something a 3d render
that feels
mundane take that prompt make something
cool in the week
and they're very um doable prompts you
can make them as big or small as you
want but it gives you a chance to
practice weekly and get you ready for
these community challenges and i'd say
just dive into the community challenge
but if you need
to kind of get
you know your c legs going get your
grasp on 3d the weekly challenges are a
great way to do so and we've had so many
artists on the discord server
take advantage of those weekly
challenges
um anytime every time i stream i
announce the winners live on stream
and when i'm not streaming that month or
when i'm not streaming during that week
um because i only stream once a month
regularly
then i'll even do a record a little
video and post it on the discord server
for the winners um and there's honorable
mentions as well so definitely i
encourage you guys to get into those
weekly challenges dive into 3d keep that
fire going and you'll be ready for the
next uh community challenge when it
comes around we do them basically twice
a year um
so
like i said subscribe if you aren't
already you'll know about them join the
discord server you'll know about it
absolutely
back to the chat here wondrous what's up
yo congratulations
um on top 100 it's amazing
really really good stuff
let's see
how would you know if your submission
made it through to the all renders you
gotta watch the allrenders video in two
two weeks from now there's a google uh
sheet where you can look up your name
and find your time code thanks to sipo
who does a little back-end work
how difficult was it to choose top 100
um
well it took a long time
um it was myself and all the moderators
in chat
and we went through every single one we
watched every single one
and uh i explained this a couple times
in the past but what i'll do is i'll
actually i'll go through and i'll try
and choose the top 125.
i'll choose the top 125.
that way i don't have to go back through
because i chose 80 and i have to go back
through everything no i'll choose a
little bit more than i think
i'll need
and we actually landed on 124
somehow that worked out
and then i take that 124 and with the
moderators we had pulled 24 of the
renders to choose the top 100 and it
took hours and hours and days and days
and days
to pull through and
and really make the top 100 and then it
takes
way more time actually to order those
renders with the music the custom music
that's being made because i can't just
slap the renders in and put the music on
and call it done
all of these renders are hand placed
with the music so you guys will see next
weekend when the top 100 comes out how
well all this stuff fits and and meshes
together i can't wait for y'all to see
it so cool
the music that my buddy fever can put
together for this is
i think it's some of the best work he's
ever done
uh
he did the alternate realities music
and and this
music
man it's good
back to chat what do you all got
let's see
uh crewentus that is
the mindset i love this challenge it's
been an honor to be there even though
you did not make top 100 congratulations
to everyone
i love that
that that uh
that attitude it's a very good attitude
it's very healthy very positive
um
thank you for giving your thanks to
everybody to everyone here in the chat
who is positive and excited about this
thank you so much
thank you thank you so much for keeping
it positive
um keep getting inspired
you guys are holding it down for us
thank you so much
guys are looking for personal feedback
that wasn't in top 100 unfortunately i
can't do that because i'm
like there's too many people there's too
many renders
uh i i think
the best way is for y'all to take
let's see how
i i'm hoping that any of the info and
any of the
um
things that we touched on here me and
freddie touched on
across the stream
i'm hoping that you can take that and
internalize it and ask yourself these
questions with your art i know you all
would love some one-on-one time there's
just not enough time to do it all
um i hope that you can learn from
the create the the critiques that we're
giving to other renders take that
personalize it to yourself ask yourself
those questions
um that's the best i can do literally
right now sitting in this chair talking
to you right now seeing you in the chat
i know there's a lot of you asking for
that stuff
um
how long does it take to come up with
the next challenge
a long time
we i think we have the idea for the next
one
we have to refine it we have to ask
ourselves like what would it actually
look like but in theory we have like the
global kind of vibe for it
and i think the more we do them the more
ideas we have the more we're thinking
about them the more ideas we have
and i really want to push it and do
something different i
i think the only thing i'm going to get
into this time the only little teaser
i'll say this time is i would like to do
something
non-character based
next time
i want to do something different next
time
see
[Music]
um
internet dweller let me tell you this
you think resolve messed up your
resolution and gotcha dq'd
maybe there's hope
because like i said what i really try to
do is include as many people in this as
possible
i know we went hard on
it's tough to say this it's tough to say
this because i don't want to give you
guys the the idea that the technical
limitations and the technical
specifications don't matter because they
do
basically the more people
that
submit improper technical specifications
the the less people that make it into
the all renders because i am going
through and i am trying to fix as many
of your technical problems as i can
but there's only so much time i have
and the more technical issues there are
the less time there is to fix them all i
can't fix them all i won't fix them all
i will fix some
but i can't fix them all
if you submitted like a 1920x1080 render
with the black bars i'll be honest with
you
i dropped that into davinci
it looks normal
because the black bars are beyond the
bounds of the of the frame you know so
it looks normal it does not break the
montage
you're good
you're good
um
don't use that as an excuse
to submit improper technical specs
if you do you run the risk of not being
in these montages
but
let's focus on let's focus on the
positive here
y'all um
looking at the app punishers in chat
here
what y'all saying how y'all doing
okay maximus you have a question about
schooling in 3d art i can only speak to
my personal experience
i
um
i taught myself i learned through
videocopilot.net
i learned through experimenting through
trial and error
um i learned through freddy i learned
through saminiko
i learned through a lot of people on
youtube winbush
ej over at i design um
grayscale gorilla octane jesus
william foshee to name some recent
people
um
it came from my personal
like draw and desire to learn 3d or to
learn vfx or learn filmmaking et cetera
and that personal draw and inspiration
like push me to do it myself and to make
mistakes and learn from the mistakes
so that that drove me i i didn't need
school to like force me to to learn it
for some people that's what you need and
that's okay it's just different that's
all
school also helps you with contacts if
you don't really have people
in your area who are doing 3d or vfx or
even your passion
going to school will all of a sudden
introduce you to a ton of people doing
that okay so it's very great for
contacts and friends and to be around
people who are better than you to learn
from so that's amazing
um
but we also have discord you know we
have youtube we have the internet and we
can join groups of people without being
there in person
um i'm not for
like
let's see
school's also expensive
um
so there's that
right just know that
it is expensive
but that doesn't mean it's
not worth it so
it you know it depends for different
people
um
there's some really cool people going to
some really really cool schools right
now
um and that would be the most exciting
thing in the world right now if i was
um if i was you know back then
a little younger going to college going
to a school to learn 3d or vfx would be
so awesome uh it's just really guys it
just what makes you inspired it's what
gets you gets you excited so
that'll be my thoughts on that
maximus um
looking at the punisher app punishers in
the chat here
ahoon
i'm glad you had a good time with this
one
oh man there's so many there's so many
tactile file thank you for the super
chat congrats on finishing the contest
it was a lot of work can't wait to see
the montages me too can't wait for you
to see them all they're going to be so
cool they're so inspiring i get the
chills every time i watch it i hope you
all do as well
ah
cup
schnitzel
thank you for that super chat is it true
um
let's see the entry with a guy on a g
and a g and the river was submitted
after the deadline heck no i did not use
anybody who submitted after the deadline
i would never do such a thing no that is
not true
um i've cut it off on the google sheet
anyone who submitted past midnight or 11
59 pm pst on after that 24 hour
extension we gave because the server
went down not considered so don't worry
about it
um which is sad because you know you
work so hard to do
the coolest thing ever during that month
but you don't get in because you could
pass the deadline it's terrifying
i'm very sad
will i only render it unreal now
absolutely not c4d i'll be going back
i used it for uh for my latest render as
well
gandalf you're welcome i'm glad you were
pushed to do something cool
start studying vfx and animation
i got a question for y'all if you guys
submitted to this challenge give me a
thumbs up um if
let's see
if you submitted give me a thumbs up i
want to see how many people are in here
or if you're just watching and enjoying
the art just give me a little smiley
face i'm curious to see what the ratio
of people is like
3dp how long have i been doing vfx in 3d
i've been doing it since
technically since 2006. if you want to
consider vfx as me adding muzzle flashes
to my windows movie maker
little scenes uh then that would be
since 2006 which would be about 16
years yeah we got thumbs ups
lots of thumbs ups y'all thank you so
much thanks for sticking around with me
too a lot of smiley faces too that's
what's up
so many people just here to enjoy the
art that's great news
more people just here to enjoy the art
that is that's awesome
sweet
oh we do a poll all right
um let's see did you submit
art for this challenge
we got yes and no
let's see
crazy it's 50
what the heck
that's nuts
y'all there's a poll at the top if you
uh if you see it
i'd be curious to see what your answers
are
give me a little favor get a little
statistics going
i'll hang out with the offer a little
bit more answer some q a
uh really can't thank y'all enough for
for working hard and and submitting to
this challenge and uh for hanging with
me for how many hours
four hours now you all have hung with me
so thank you if you i know some of you
are staying up very late or waking up
very early
so i really thank you a lot
tips for more photo realistic renders
i think lighting is the big is one of
the biggest things lighting
um and at a certain point photo
realistic renders are going to require a
lot of detail
all this stuff here
on my desk
that those are all individual models
some of them might be custom
um you got to go find a bass guitar
travel case you got to do surface
imperfections
um
and this is a very simple scene there's
a lot to do if i was to leave right
you'd have to you'd have to model a
chair you'd have to find a chair
um
you know you'd have to make sure your
lighting is right it really comes down
to the lighting i think photorealistic
renders have a lot of
a lot of great lighting and it's the
first thing that's off for me when i
look at a render and it just looks uh
it's usually the lighting and to be
honest with y'all
um
so much of y'all could benefit from
lighting from lighting your scenes you
just need to light it
and you're like well what does that mean
how do i light something well
maybe i'll make a video on it because so
many of you all could benefit
from lighting your scene
and giving it a little bit more spice
um
i think that's a good video to do
yeah
let's see
we got 55 of people just observing
hanging out with me and 45 percent of
people
actually submitting art that is a great
that's a great ratio
sam mirror
wow thank you
thank you very much for that super chat
you learned a lot
thank you very much for the challenge
hope i'm going to join you guys next
year's competition
that's what's up that's all i could ask
is that you had a good time and that you
learned stuff and you're excited
to keep making stuff whether you do it
for the challenge or not i'm just glad
that
you know you're working on your passion
and having a good time
while you're doing it so thank you for
the support thank you for that super
chat it's very very helpful um it allows
me to keep doing this stuff full time
if you guys want to keep supporting
there's a patreon in the description
first link at the top
there's a five dollar tier which gets
you access full access to um
the discord is pretty much open at this
point
um i think it gets you a little bit more
access on the discord and just like a
general kind of support and then we have
uh the pro tier which gives you access
to the lounge and all my assets and
stuff
um i'll upload there and they're just
yours for free
let's see let's see
any more things sunil what's up yo
thanks for that thanks for that super
chat super cool
rugrats yes i am looking forward to the
next non-character based challenge
myself we want to mix it up next time do
something different
hmm all right mike sharks
you're still learning blender
would blender be considered an industry
standard still or is it worth learning
something like c4d so i don't think
well here's what
i um as far as i take it maya is the
industry standard
um
i don't work in studios
i don't work at a vfx production house
so i don't
i don't know specifically what is going
on there but as far as i understand maya
is the industry standard
um
would you you're saying was learning
blender should you switch to c4d
i
don't
think so unless you have a really good
reason to like
if you're trying to aim for a very
specific
studio to get into and they require you
to know a certain program then yeah it
would probably make sense to learn that
program
but if you're just starting out and you
are enjoying 3d
i wouldn't say you need to switch to
anything if something is working for you
so if blender is that thing that's
working for you keep it up and if it
keeps you inspired keep going in that
direction i don't think you need to make
things more difficult for yourself
unless you have a good reason to do so
like when i switch i say switch i did
not switch from c40 to unreal
i wanted to learn unreal to add it to
the tool belt right so
that was
a pretty painful process because i was
out of my comfort zone and i could
easily have gone back to c4d and just
did what i was trying to do in unreal
but in c4d
um but i was like no i
i struggled with the reason i was
learning unreal
and the whole reason i was learning
unreal is because oh cause i want to do
it in real time i want to be able to
have these like photoreal
results in real time but that's not
really the case like your viewport
render isn't the maxed out
final render that comes from an actual
render granted it's much faster than
like 15 minutes per frame
but it's still a render so like if i
have to render then why am i not back in
c4d
and i had to like
really struggle with that and find the
reason why the heck i'm learning unreal
engine and at the end of the day it was
just really fun i was having a fun time
in it
and i do think that unreal is the future
and
i'm still looking for those reasons like
why do i keep going why do i keep going
at the end of the day it's because i'm
enjoying my time in the program i'm
enjoying my time
doing this art
so keep going no reason to make things
more difficult on yourself for no reason
how many content creators i'd recommend
for maya
sir wade i think might be like the first
dude that comes to my mind
he was an animator at dreamworks
and he left to pursue his youtube
channel so he's got a lot of good stuff
sir wade s-i-r-w-a-d-e
qual what's up yo thanks for the super
chat really hope for a breakdown of the
time-lapse one even if i'm not top 100
i've learned a lot and i hope my master
roshi render
made you laugh i saw some master roshi
renders i did
um
so yes there will be
well i can't say that for a fact
i believe october 15th
we're going to be doing a winner's
stream and you're like october 15th
that's so far from now well we gotta get
to top 100 montage we gotta do all the
render the all renders montage
and that's uh september
and then i think the first thing up
the next the very next stream is the
winter stream so hopefully we'll have
anna on
and
they can talk about their process and
their breakdown we'll talk with anna for
hopefully 30 minutes
of course i have to reach out to the
winners see if they're available and
they're down for that
um but that is the plan is to is to
reach out to the winners get them to
come on and do a little breakdown
amazing
it's going to be about that time y'all
got a thousand people still chilling
with me that's awesome though
heck yeah
oh i'm beat
all right y'all want to see my
render right i'll show you my render
it's hot in this room
oh
so this is where i'm at
the last thing i need to do is update
the
like video screen here to replicate
the first render
of the montage because i'm going to have
it like seamlessly blend
i need to add text that describes what
the challenge was who participated how
many people participated you know a
bunch of cool
mind-blowing stats i want to get across
but other than that it's done
yeah i don't have any more time to work
on this other than updating kind of what
i mentioned so it feels a little long
right now
i think the text will help
and i think updating the video screen
will also help i'm gonna add a couple
little elements but
yeah i mean that's it i did it in unreal
engine this was rendered out uh with ray
traced reflections
uh i believe this was
32
samples per pixel um i'll probably do
another pass on the color correction
just because it's a little crunchy
on the top left and right
but i'm really happy with the lighting
very very happy with the lighting
i love that uh like the windows on the
side
that stepped up the render really really
nice
um
we got a couple
easter eggs in the render as well
i love the color correction in terms of
the actual color
um like i said i do need to massage it
just a little bit
um what else what else i had to hand
animate this character i had so much
trouble
with the character workflow on this one
um
it was brutal yeah i'm still trying to
figure out a good character workflow and
i managed to use dad studio to get this
character i did a custom cloth sim on
these pants
a little
rope sim there on the wires
hand animated
via reference mocap reference
it's hard work
is very very hard work
how did i model this unreal okay so a
lot of this is kit bash yes this is
using um qxel mega scans lots of quixote
mega scans
the ground texture is actually my own
texture that i made
i got a whole video on how to make
custom textures it's the endless
concrete
video so i did that
and a lot of this is like marketplace
assets like this little trolley on the
right that cart with the generator the
wires are all done inside of c4d i
simmed those
um the desk on the left
those are props from the matrix pack
those are all it's all free we got kit
bash buildings in the background kit
bash 3d buildings in the back i'm using
my surface imperfections on the window
um ultra dynamic sky
uh plug-in in unreal engine for the sky
i
built those like trusses
out of just simple um
cylinders that i pieced together so
nothing is like
you know polygon perfect
it's more of a block out but it just
works for what i need it to be right
um
what else what else yeah like the
concrete
columns and pillars on top and sides are
all uh
um
quicksole mega scans assets
the little crocs on the bottom left
those are cg trader assets most of this
stuff is assets and
uh sprinkled with custom materials that
i made the daz character
um and some c4d
uh simulated
cables and stuff
and that that's pretty much it you know
i'm i'm definitely more interested in
building an environment using existing
assets i don't need to sit here and
and model everything from scratch like
those
that's fun it is fun but just in the
time limit that i have it it's
impossible
can you point out the easter eggs you'll
have to find them easter eggs
can't do that work for you
yeah built out that like custom vr
screen in after effects too
that was
that's quite a lot of work
and you can see it's supposed to like
blend in right
let's see if i can go to the last frame
it blends into like that third place
render
when i switched the order of things i
started this one so i'm gonna have to go
back in and like
i did this really cool thing actually um
that i'll talk about in my art breakdown
for the scene but uh
i basically
camera projected
a render
onto
this like little stage layout in c4d
and
i had a second camera
shoot out these different angles um
or the the the the different walls so it
looks all distorted based on the angle
i'm i'm shooting it from until we land
in this camera projected
angle very specific and then it
perfectly lines up so i'm going to talk
a little bit about that
in my breakdown as well
coming later in october
alwyn what's up
my chance of failure is absolute zero
that is what i like to hear
heck yeah
amazing
uh we also let's see
we got 39 people who submitted art
worked on the challenge and we have 61
people who did not cool
the statistics are building up
although i think that might be it
i my throat hurts from talking too much
i'm starving i need some food
thank you guys so much for joining me
on these top 100 uh renders here with
freddy
thank you for participating thanks for
working hard y'all are the best
keep it up right i'll be seeing you guys
on the server um pretty soon here we got
the weekly challenge going mundane is
the prompt if you just submitted art if
you cranked hard in the month
take a break okay you don't have to hop
right into these weeklies
take a break enjoy yourself i know i'm
taking a break i'm gonna wrap up the top
100 comes out next weekend the top 100
montage comes out next weekend it's
gonna be incredible custom music and
everything the following weekend we got
the all renders but i'm gonna be away um
at uh half res this next week
so i will be posting early um
scheduling that upload and going live
from chicago and then i'm also going to
be doing the all renders montage from
virginia at camp mograph
so i'm going to be taking a little break
all right i've got some content to come
out
while i'm chilling i'm going to need it
all right
but guys thank you thank you thank you
so much um to my moderators in the chat
thank you all so much sonamonte behind
the scenes running in a production
love you dude thank you so much
with that
we're going to bounce here guys
thank you stay inspired take a break
have a good one be healthy see y'all
peace
[Music]
ten
[Music]